we had a hearing today
and it was streamed live we get to watch
as
we heard from the trump campaign's
lawyer under oath
about evidence that there was voter
fraud in many states
again let me stress that for you because
many on the left in the mainstream media
don't seem to understand this
the trump campaign lawyers stated
definitively
under oath this is our evidence of voter
fraud
if you think they're lying please you
know
send the prosecutor and give me some
perjury charges all right make it happen
but for now you can't keep saying they
have not presented their case under oath
and you can't keep saying there's no
evidence because they certainly
presented it
well rand paul steps up and he says in
many ways the election was stolen there
was front and something must be done
he went she he didn't go as far as to
say because of fraud which is the
fancy phrase that youtube will ban us
for but he did make a pretty bold
statement
and that means to many people rand paul
is going to be the senator who joins
the house member republican probably mo
brooks and disputes the electoral vote
come january 6
and in my opinion this means nothing
because the public republicans have no
political willpower and probably will do
nothing and
mitch mcconnell is already begging
republicans to roll over and let the
democrats do what they want
so i certainly imagine that come january
6 you may see some principled
republicans
and you'll see most of them go but i
don't wanna can't we just let the
democrats do it it's so much easier
welcome to politics everybody today
we're hanging out with jack murphy hey
everybody good to be back
yeah schedule got messed up for a little
bit but here we are wednesday night
good to see you lydia made it through
the blizzard made it through the
blizzard you know nothing was gonna keep
me away tonight
nothing at all four-wheel drive 35 miles
an hour
nice and slow yeah man so when when they
says like it's like it's the biggest
nor'easter in a decade or whatever
that's that's
you know the area and people were like
is jack gonna be safe he's gonna make it
i was like i was
like jack's driving four by four he's
gonna he's not gonna he's gonna not
gonna flinch from this tim did he
scoffed when i said
i don't know i told jack maybe he
shouldn't come up he did yeah ian did
and then lydia went out in the street
took a picture yeah it's all good
don't worry about it i'm from midwest
man i can deal with this plus in dc
it snowed 40 inches and then like two
days later it snowed 40 inches again
oh wait recently yeah 10 years ago oh
it's called snowmageddon
yeah so that's 12 inches this is nothing
yeah i know not only that i was like if
if jack can't make it up while being
this you know like six foot five bearded
man
i'd i would demand he walk here yeah the
rugged snow like i'm coming on this one
nothing's gonna stop me nothing's gonna
stop me from seeing you i missed you
i've missed you ian um and we don't live
on a mountaintop like
carolina was like over dramatizing like
how far
deep into the world we actually kind of
do yeah
not the top top because it goes up more
in the back but uh
we we're in mountainous areas definitely
but you know it's not like everest or
anything
but it's elevated there's a freeway yeah
well luke's hanging out too
well hi i am the optimistic residential
uncle eddie
it's good to be here thanks for having
me that's it yeah
you normally have some ridiculous dumb
thing to say yeah
rico no no shoveled the ice and snow
off his rv today yeah he got video of it
yes and he was trying to throw snowballs
but he's his aim was awful terrible
next time do the sidewalk to the door
while you're at it
but we but but some uh we have we have a
guy
who lives close by has a plow the whole
the tim's
12 mile approach you know from the
street up the driveway
takes about 25 minutes to drive it up
the whole thing was totally flat
we tried we tried using an old skate
deck to go down it
but you start going so fast because it's
it's it's not
it wasn't snow it was slush and sleet
and like ice
is that why there was just that one
random skate deck on the porch
yeah yeah soaking wet that was because
we were jumping on it and then once you
get to like 60 miles an hour you give up
and then slide
no we didn't go that fast you could
totally and then you'd lose control and
just flip
out but the cool thing about it is when
you fall you just slide down
down the asphalt it's just you know it's
ice it's cold that's about it
so yeah that's what's going on here and
uh one more thing i'll give a shout out
to um
to verizon for um six months ago we were
supposed to have internet installed they
finally show up installed the wrong box
told us they finished the job they did
we have no way to connect to it
and uh now we're sitting here and uh the
verizon keeps calling us being like
but it's already set up and i'm like
dude there's nothing that connects
we had an i.t guy come out and he's like
you can't connect to this it's a verizon
equipment it's the magic of that
it's amazing your 2400 dial dial up here
has been performing so well
and and the satellite too but we
recently did some improvements because
the power kept cutting out
and i don't know why because we didn't
change anything but we decided to
split the the electrical load to
different circuits
and then we put the internet on uh a
different line as well so it's
closer to the moment i think we should
be should be good nothing getting in our
way tonight
ladies and gentlemen for everything
we've just gone through the
the the you know jack murphy dragging
his
his sleigh through the snow to make it
here
bare hands uh smash that like button
subscribe to notification bell
but let's read this news here man let's
talk about rand paul claiming the
election was in many ways stolen
now as all of you know yes
let's not let's not play games we don't
want to get the stream taken off the air
and youtube has said that if you say
certain things in combination
they'll just take down the clip what
combos like iraq saddam hussein weapons
of mass destruction
that's okay oh that's okay yeah you can
say that you can say those smashed up
yeah yeah you can say you can say uh you
can lie to the american people east
and uh call for a repeated war which
gets us into this 20-year
quagmire and you can claim that trump is
a russian asset still
to this day working for the soviets not
just russia
because they said 1987. all right they
said 1987
and you you are okay but if you claim
the
two things the first is that there's
widespread voter fraud or error and the
second you combine that with a statement
that it changed the outcome
they remove your content boom just gone
from from youtube
which is really interesting considering
a lot of what's coming out right now and
this statement from rand paul which i
will now read
the hill reports quote the fraud
happened
the election in many ways was stolen and
the only way it will be fixed is by
in the future reinforcing the laws paul
said during a hearing
with testimony from christopher krebs
the president's former cyber security
chief who was fired by trump after he
reported there was no interference in
the election
paul made the remarks as krebs wearing a
mask looked unskeptically his arms
crossed
in front of his chest thanks for that uh
the hill the remarks were notable
because paul is seen as one of the
senators who might join a bid by rhett
mo brooks
to challenge the election's outcome and
overturn the results in several states
despite a series of court decisions that
have rejected claims of widespread fraud
as unsubstantiated
that is false fake news from the hill
most of these cases as far as i know i
could and it's challenging because
there's many
were procedural grounds in fact i'll put
it this way maybe that's true but in the
hearing it was stated by numerous people
that the claims in these lawsuits
pertain to fraud
were never actually ruled on the merits
so they didn't say necessarily it was
unsubstantiated
that there was widespread fraud they
said things like you have no standing
or it's too late to sue or you know this
is a criminal matter that must be
investigated and not for a civil court
or whatever
i'll also point out kris krebs who said
there was no interference
he said specifically from a security
perspective
security because he's a cyber security
guy he said fraud well that's a criminal
matter i have nothing to do with
so that's really important we're talking
about this now
i don't know uh if rand paul actually
actually will step
up especially i don't know if you heard
jack mitch mcconnell basically saying
you know leave trump high and dry don't
do this i don't think we can count on
the gop for support in this matter
as much as i would like to i'm curious
about rand paul going out on a limb here
what do you i mean what do you mean well
you know just he's always sort of been a
renegade right and doing his own thing
and you know he's really making kind of
a stand here him and ted cruz have
really
stepped up taking some action to try to
you know investigate at least
see what's happening yeah and uh and and
take a principled stand
i guess ran's comfortable out there by
himself huh he's always been he's always
he
what do you filibuster the nda the
defense bill yeah
that's supportive of trump trump says
he's gonna veto i don't know if he can
because
republicans and democrats are alike are
like war good
more war fantastic we don't care what
trump thinks ted cruz started smoking
pot like
six years ago is that your what i don't
know it just seems like he started
smoking pot
he totally changed he used to be this
uptight nerd and then he started growing
a beer now he's like this hippie
republican
[Laughter]
i mean no other explanation yeah he took
mushrooms or something
well come january 6 we're going to find
out
i'm willing to bet the republicans with
absolutely zero political willpower
are going to sit back and be like to do
anyone dude
rand paul is not a republican like he's
a republican but he's not
anything like mitch mcconnell like he's
a completely different
uh uh creature like yeah he is i would
maybe he's like a libertarian just he is
very libertarian yeah
yes he's a lot like his dad but because
the libertarian party has no
representation in our government
they run as republicans it's why bernie
runs as a democrat
yeah but the interesting thing about the
progressive left is that bernie
when it became obvious that he wasn't
going to win
or i should say that when he just when
he folded because he should have kept
pushing it
you know he just dropped down and
started licking the feet of the of the
dnc establishment
where trump was like no excuse me excuse
me no
no and then he took over and then the
republicans it was it was inverted it's
interesting
bernie and the progressives were forced
to drop down and
beg the establishment for some kind of
time and and presence
and they barely get any leverage trump
was the other way around
trump took over and the establishment
republicans were like oh
no what do we do you're the trump party
now baby so they had to listen to what
trump wanted you know that they had
they had to get behind trump to the best
you know to a certain extent
and it's really funny how many trump
supporters really did say okay to the
republicans
and now now things are getting totally
different i mean first of all i'll tell
you
when i see memes from trump supporters
mocking police officers i don't know if
you saw this one
because you saw what happened in
michigan where the the cop at the state
capitol
wouldn't let the republican elect
electoral candidates sorry in the
building
so then all of a sudden trump supporters
posting memes basically saying these
these cops are you know
not heroes they only care about their
paycheck and not the will you know not
the constitution stuff like that
so that sentiment's already changed and
now they're basically
going nuts after mitch mcconnell saying
it's time for him to
you know for a new party leader i think
it's definitely fair to say that the gop
is fractured
and that the political realignment is
happening right now in a very
interesting way where a lot of people
who are anti-establishment are learning
that they have a lot more in common
than they have different from each other
but also very interestingly the
washington examiner also just tweeted
that in nevada there are there are still
legal arguments that quote 42
000 people voted more than once that at
least 1
500 dead people voted and that 19 000
people
uh voted even though they didn't live in
nevada so we're still
still hearing some of these arguments
will they actually translate that means
something
that was stated under oath yes by a
trump campaign lawyer exactly
so if they think there's no evidence and
he's lying congratulations
you got him the trump campaign lawyer is
going to go to prison for lying to the
senate under oath congratulations there
you go
so how about now we get his files we
present them in a court of law
that way you can all send the trump
campaign lawyer to jail how does that
sound
never will happen too much they don't
they don't want these guys to
go to court of course they don't want
the merits presented absolutely not no
discovery none of that
yeah when when uh the trump lawsuit i
think was in nevada the judges didn't
even
the court didn't even want to look at
the evidence they were like no no
no we're not going to do that the
supreme court which is in favor of him
which was selected
there's a large number of people that
were selected by him for the supreme
court
that were from the 2000 bush v gore case
they they're like oh we don't want to
hear it as well like like
like what else do what what other you
know writings on the wall
do we need to to see that there's a big
rift within the establishment
i i don't get why the court gets to pick
what they
decide to look at like we they wrote
they work for us so why don't we just
give them what to look at they're an
appellate court
not a trial court so they still work for
the people right
but they're in appellate courts right so
the way it works is you can
file in court and have your trial and
then the judge issues their ruling
congratulations you're a citizen you
have that right
now appeals courts they can reject you
and say the law was upheld
so when the supreme court says we're not
going to look at it usually it's because
they're like this decision was legit
buy we you know we're not going to we're
not going to bother with it that
there you go usually but in this
situation in this situation it was
really different because
texas the lawsuit from the states it's
uh it's called original jurisdiction
meaning who does a state go to when
they're filing
a uh you know lawsuit against another
state they can't go to a circuit court
because a circuit might be in
one of these states or on totally
unrelated so they've they filed the
supreme court
alito and thomas believe they're
obligated to take up these claims
to represent this you know to oversee
these disputes between the states
but apparently trump's appointees
gorsuch uh
amy coney barrett kavanaugh did not
agree and felt that they have the right
to
say no to these to these uh cases
we'll see if anything comes of it i
think one of the one of the important
things people need to realize about
whether or not the election was stolen
or anything
right now we're well past the point of
the election
i don't think at this point the election
matters in any anyway all right
the media said joe biden won the
electoral college came and had their
official votes and they said joe biden
they voted for joe biden joe biden gets
the gets the uh
the electoral votes what we're talking
about right now is trump versus
the establishment can trump win in this
ongoing fight
the numbers of votes don't matter as far
as i'm concerned
okay you know why we get a report out of
antrim uh
and antrim in uh michigan where a guy
straight up says
these machines are designed to have
massive errors like that that was
his assessment and we had hunter evelyn
on the show and he said
i don't believe it effectively he said
this guy's a trump supporter and he's
crazy he's put out false information
before and i'm like great
that's exactly my point the left is
going to be like why would i believe
this report from a trump supporter and i
go
you're it's a great point why would i
believe anyone who's not a trump
supporter when they come to refute it in
which case all that really matters
confidence legitimacy and influence
trump wins if
more people believe in him than anything
else
i don't know if that's going to happen
especially with people like linwood and
sidney powell
really really hurting trump's legitimacy
like seriously hurting it
when regular people are not paying
attention and you get some crazy kraken
story
that you know hugo chavez or whatever i
want to be like what
what i don't what is that that sounds
crazy to me and so that hurts trump's
legitimacy
if they came out and made a
constitutional argument about uh
changing the rules a regular person says
wow that's a you know interesting
constitution oh yeah violation of the
constitution i understand that
trump needs to convince more people
because right now i'll tell you this if
100 million people woke up today
in the you know or tomorrow morning and
all said trump is president
trump would be president regardless of
it like seriously
if everyone in this country just one day
said the constitution doesn't exist
then it wouldn't exist it its power is
held in the fact that people swear an
oath to it that we we we believe in the
system
we have confidence the system exists and
that's what matters so trump is fighting
a kind of battle to prove some kind of
legitimacy the reason it's going through
the courts
and the reason it's going to go to
january 6 when they dispute is to
use the system that exists now to assert
legitimacy
that's it but i'll tell you this they
say it's over
that fair right they do the they did
political betting i think they're based
in the uk
said december 14th the electoral college
voted joe biden has won the presidency a
bunch of trump supporters got really mad
started you know tweeting at him saying
what do you mean like they haven't even
counted the votes yet
and they're like well you have a problem
with it we'll revisit later the reason
betfair probably paid
out is because they want to get their
taxes in before the end of the year you
know their losses and their like i guess
the way you can put it is
they take all this money for bets and if
they hold on to it into the next year
that's all revenue plus
so they need those losses they need to
be like here's what we paid out and lost
we'll come back to it later if trump
somehow becomes president it might even
be kamal harris
i mean there's look joe biden was
coughing up a storm he's an old man
and he announced he's going to be taking
the covid vaccine
next week oh my god so uh anaphylaxis
yeah that's yeah that's publicly i think
he'll be fine but uh
i'm not saying he won't i'm not saying
he won't i'm just adding another layer
to that
he's gonna be doing that as well so
what's happening is
there's a system that exists there are
there are stamps on envelopes
certification right official governor's
seal that's the kind of thing
that a regular person looks at and says
i recognize that as legitimate
but what if someone came to you with a
seal that said you know
office of the the new what we saw we saw
uh
a lawsuit that went to the that signed
on for the texas
laws the texas lawsuit got two uh uh
amicus
uh editions from new california and new
nevada yeah what was that
states which do not exist yeah but what
if someone
believed it what if the media announced
what if every news outlet said
the state of new nevada now exists and
here's its territory people would be
like wow and they believe it
then when someone sues people would be
right there that is a thing right
so that's what the media has been
relentlessly saying joe biden's
president-elect even though
president-elect doesn't determine until
january 6 they want him to be
legitimized
trump is fighting for legitimacy the
best path for trump to get legitimacy is
on january 6 at this point
and it's extremely unlikely maybe maybe
what happens
is that some information comes out you
know from now until then
and then you have these republican
electoral candidates who cast their
votes
procedurally so then you know something
flips and then
the count says you know republicans
support trump democrats support biden
there's a dispute it goes to supreme
court or whatever who knows trump ends
up winning something like that
it's using the system's legitimacy to
claim you are president if i tell you
i think that you know when they're
saying it's over now
then they're then then they're saying
but on january 6 we'll see trump's final
plan
it's like trump it's not over
election-wise until january 20th
when joe biden you know swears on oath
and he's sworn into the oval office and
all that stuff
and trump leaves what if trump doesn't
leave
he will leave if he's supposed to yeah i
believe that 100
what you bring up is something very
interesting though is about what
binds us what binds us as people and
it's about
shared imagined imagine stories
right it's just this thing in our
imagination that we know somebody else
believes and so we believe the same
imagines
you know order the same story and that's
what makes our tribes and so
right now everything is about who can be
the fastest with the story and the
narrative who can have
flood the zone with the most information
and the most stories that
people can latch on to and believe our
reality and that's why the
the stop the steel guys are keep going
and the protests keep going and the
never give up no black pill people keep
going
because you're right there it is about
just what people believe
that's just that can shape reality
that's how the us dollar works
this is faith historically a tortured
existence for human beings you know why
i was reading about the the the war for
independence the revolutionary war
and you know back in the day we talked
about before when they signed the
declaration of independence
there were drafts before they signed it
they signed it on
july 2nd i believe and then the
announcement was like july 4th i guess
and that's when like the final version
came out or something
but it wasn't until i think what was the
date was it october
29th maybe can't remember where the king
addressed parliament for the first time
after reading the declaration
months went by like with nothing
happening
and then how long until they actually
sent the you know the british
expeditionary force to the colonies to
quell the rebellion it probably was a
year
now realistically the revolutionary war
was already happening
it was happening i think for like two
years before they signed the declaration
of independence
because the colonies were already in
revolt so it'd been going on for a long
time
but this is what i was saying a long
time ago you used to you'd be sitting on
your farm or whatever or you'd be
working on someone's farm whatever you
did
and then you know a postal writer would
come and be like we have a lot
from the king it you know it's finally
arrived after three months
and you read it and it says like you
know you suck and you're like oh yeah
well you suck send it back and then
three months later the king gets it
a year goes by before any real action is
taken so you were living your life you
were eating food with your friends and
your family and you were working
enjoying yourself and in the sun
and all the political stuff was so
stretched out
once every other month you'd have like
some kind of political thing happen and
you'd be like ah
now it's every day every minute
something changes i wake up
and there's like 10 stories of like
crazy apocalyptic news revelations
rand paul mitch mcconnell yeah the dni
chief it's over
and this is why we had elections in
novembers and inaugurations in january
because it took people to travel
so long across the country to get to
washington
dc and set everything up for themselves
but right now there is a lot to say
about this inundation of information of
data
and also who controls it the algorithms
that are set
and how they play on our emotions
feelings and larger expansion of life
which
has a huge detrimental effect in my
opinion there's a lot to say about that
sorry i cut you off
well the first thing was that we we was
back in the day it took so long to get
information that we
actually needed people to represent us
in politics
and now we don't yeah um
i think we do no no way dude you get all
your information immediately you can
interact with anyone in the world
immediately you do not need other people
to represent you anymore that's wrong
that's completely i disagree with you
well you're you're factually okay that's
factually tell me how because
how much how much news do you read every
day as much as i want but you do want is
it enough to know
who michael oslachevsky is
that's a bizarre question no it isn't
why
when i'm talking about whether is it
enough i don't know you can always read
the answer
is no because some but if i need a job
some people's jobs
is to collect and disseminate
information and i can't expect a plumber
or a tradesman
to know everything about what's going on
in the world they say listen bro
i can make the best aqueduct system
you've ever seen in the world
and you would be envious of my skill and
i would say you're totally correct and
they'd say but you know what i don't
know who any of these guys are
who are changing money who are
negotiating between these countries i
need someone who can be dedicated to
that field of work
they're allowed to give up their power
if they want but they should not be
forced to give up their power
direct democracy doesn't work it's chaos
it's mob rule
and a bunch of people who have no idea
what's going on asserting rights
and like their right to control and
manipulate the system to agree like to
to to a direct democracy degree we need
a direct republic
i'm not talking about jamaica what is it
where a bunch of us
in our district can vote and then that
becomes the year or nay we don't need to
vote for someone to go say yay or nay
for us
maybe um the other thing i was thinking
is that
regarding the media you know joseph
goebbels he was hitler's minister of
propaganda
his quote that if you if you tell a lie
big enough and repeat it
keep repeating it that people eventually
come to believe it he went on to
elaborate about lying just continuously
lying
let me tell you a story about uh to
create the myth let me tell you a story
about reddit
when uh i think it was i think was the
boston bombing actually
reddit was convinced that they had found
the suspect
and they started posting photos in the
name and the community
all got together and made their decree
of who the bad guy really was
and they were wrong and that's the
problem with
mob voting or mob rule or you know
i remember being on the ground in boston
after that bombing happened i drove up
from new york city and just hearing all
the fake news reports going around and
seeing it translated with panic in the
streets of saying
we got to look out you got to fight for
this guy and people not know i know his
name i don't say his name though because
he was innocent
and so the concern is i think
representative
constitutional republic is a good thing
i think the problem is we have corrupt
representatives for the most part
almost all of them except for a small
handful
but when you have a bunch of people like
even even a
you know a direct republic it's an
interesting concept because
it would you'd still have the electoral
college you'd still have you know
congress per district and everything
like that in different districts
you know all based on a certain number
of people so you'd still get you know
senators i suppose
i don't know how that actually would
work with state representation i guess
you'd still have to have senators well
no you wouldn't because okay how many
representatives are there 400 now or so
however many let's pick a number 500
500 535 people representing 535 areas
now instead of that person
saying yay or nay for that area those
people would do a mass
vote and then that area would produce a
yay or nay vote of the other 534
and then each area would give their one
535th
so what ends up happening is what we're
supposed to have
is a politician who understands the
policies
who visits the areas and understands the
needs of each area and says
if one group comes to me and says
fracking is wrong and destroying the
environment we must ban it
and another group comes to me and says
fracking is good it's the lifeblood of
western pennsylvania we would die
without it
the politician has to then make the hard
decision hmm it's a good point there's a
lot of concerns about fracking but i
think many
people may be incorrect and i can't take
away the livelihoods of people who are
who are you know impoverished and not
making that much money
so we're gonna have to make sure we have
some kind of compromise but fracking
will stand
what would happen if you did a
referendum on fracking in pennsylvania
the people in the cities would outvote
the rural areas shutting it down and
destroying all of their lives
because they don't know anything about
that area they don't live there and
they've never visited it
but when you get different districts
when you when you have districts the
districts vote for their interests
so that would make sense but when you
have senators those are the people who
are supposed to go around the state and
understand the full
issues and they try to pander to each
and every group to find that right
balance of lowest common denominator
maximum vote
the problem is parties on the ballot i
think this is a big thing we can we can
solve this problem we're talking about
the other day i don't know if you heard
us jack
we were saying take political parties
off ballots when you go to vote there's
no political parties you'll just see
names
good luck if you don't know who the
person is don't vote for him but right
now people go in and they go d
or r d r that's all they're voting for
get rid of the political parties just
vote for the person if you know the
person is well then don't vote for
that's your problem
people want to vote for our platform
though they want to know sort of what
the big picture is they want to know
what the world view is they don't want
to just
i just i disagree yeah people who vote
for democrat aren't voting because of
what they think the platform is or
whatever
they're just like democrat good
republican bad or republican good
democrat bad
like you know the story we brought up
again that the trans-satanist anarchist
who ran as a republican in the primary
and won in i think was in new hampshire
right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because people went
in and they looked at the bound they
were like republican
and then they got really mad when they
found out who they voted for that's your
problem but what we're just talking
about right now is the fact that most
people are rationally low
information yes and so if you get to the
ballot there's a little bit of
information that can help you
you're talking about putting people who
are low information rationally
into an even lower information position
yeah but
how does how does putting democrat or
republican help anyone it's hurt them
it it's hurt them because now you get
democrats who don't have to actually do
anything they just get elected
and then they do nothing so you know you
know what would really help them
if they don't know the names of these
people and so they vote randomly
it cancels everything out he says random
then but if they
if they go in and say well i know i want
to vote for you know for trump or
whatever
i don't know about the rest of these
people then trump gets the vote and they
don't vote for other people
and then the people who get into the
ones that people actually wanted and
supported
i think we're all talking about the same
thing and that's low information voters
and the problem is
people aren't informed that they're
programmed and whether it's
you know schools the mainstream media
hollywood and more than ever
social media we are seeing the
programming of individuals to think
a certain way and to have their limited
point of view
be projected in their small little echo
chambers which
prevails on social media more than ever
that reinforces people's beliefs
rather than having them open-minded
rather than have them thinking
and i think if we could just get
individuals thinking or open-minded or
set up the cultural institutions or
or you know culture crash in some ways
to to allow people to see that there's
different perspectives there's different
ideas there's different options out
there
that i think naturally human beings
would go towards those options and then
go towards a better path than the crappy
path that we are on right now i think
this is one of the most important issues
facing the country today
i think that that is a skill that we
need to teach people we call in the
liminal order we call that personal
sovereignty
and we talk about how jordan peterson
often said that people don't have ideas
but ideas have people
we want to train our guys to be people
who who identify their own beliefs
and are strong enough mentally
emotionally spiritually
physically and integrated in that
capacity so that they can
embody those values and make a choice to
live like that a deliberate conscious
choice
in your belief system because right now
there's a battlefield in your brain and
the first mover is often the one who
wins and you don't even know it let's be
honest when a person is born
they're thrown into the system and the
system chews them up and spits them out
uses and abuses them to the highest
level kids are told go get a
degree go get a loan go be in servitude
for the rest of your life
paying off something that you can't
legitimately pay off unless you're a
slave to the cog of a machine
that of course ruins any form of logical
royal sovereign
individual existence so i think that
right there is the essential key but
how do we unravel that how do we fix
that because i see a lot of institutions
i see schools mainstream media hollywood
social media
all reinforcing the establishment line
all
reinforcing the doctrine that that puts
them on this machine
that a lot of people don't know how to
escape it starts at home and it starts
with parents and it starts with fathers
leading their families and teaching
their kids these are life skills like
teach you how to hunt teach you how to
balance a checkbook teach you how to be
a sense maker
and how to be personally sovereign and
so you can choose your own ideas
and make your own selection but this is
an investment right this is an
investment and this
the reason why the investment makes more
sense now
than it may have in the past is because
the stakes are higher
the stakes are higher we're not just
simply two gentlemen disagreeing over
the size of the budget or this or that
we have a fundamental difference
in the way that we think the world and
the country should be arranged
different notions of justice different
notions of right and wrong different
notions of truth
and so we need to we need the stakes are
higher
so the the rationally ignorant or had by
an idea
sort of uh selection um the calculus is
changing
well dumb people and low iq people are
getting abused
more than ever and i think it's in
everyone's kind of best interest that
that doesn't happen because it hurts
everyone on the larger kind of
spectrum here and that's why i've been
always talking about homeschooling new
hampshire
uh has one of the biggest homeschooling
networks it also has some of the highest
iqs in all of the united states
which shows you that you know i think
it's critically essential to get away
from all these institutions
public schooling is one of them
homeschooling is a big thing i always
followed
dana martin she's a great amazing
speaker and a major proponent of
homeschooling so if you guys are looking
into
potentially getting into that to
definitely probably check out dana
martin
and uh you know especially if you have a
young child coming on the way
i i would never ever want my kid to go
through a public school system that i
went
through in new york city because it was
absolutely hard so so right now
you have there's actually a really
really funny meme i saw i'll start over
it was the bell curve you know and on
the on the back it was a really really
stupid looking like drooling person that
said trump one
in the middle is the average and it says
biden one and at the end it's the big
brained glasses wearing guy saying trump
won
and and the way the way i look at that
is not necessarily that it's correct but
on the right you certainly have a lot of
dumb people who support trump
but you have a lot of smart people and
uh you can look at
not necessarily everyone who's like
intellectual dark web types but like
moderate
disaffected liberals former democrats
people who were
consciously looking at what's going on
and saying i'm going to make a decision
this is not the right choice this is so
certainly you still have your left and
right tribalists are democrats
republicans
but in the traditional political system
it was just the exploitation
of the low information voter un for both
parties
but now with trump and with bernie to a
certain degree
you have more active individuals
unfortunately i think the left has fake
progressive grifters and high profile
positions who
claim to represent the left but really
don't i'm not going to say who they are
but they're very prominent
and then on the right you have people
who are probably accused of the same
thing
but more nuanced discussions more debate
and an actual interest in intellectual
honesty and i gave you a really good
example it was ken bone
you guys remember ken bone oh yeah yeah
everyone everyone loved it was it the
red sweatshirt guy
in 2016 election he tweeted that he was
going to be voting for i think joe
jorgensen was that what was happening
and and he said amazingly all the trump
supporters were like stand up for what
you believe in man we respect you good
for you
and the left were screaming in his face
you're voting for
trump you know my favorite thing is when
people would say
they vote when they would be like if you
vote if you don't vote for
for biden you're essentially voting for
trump and then you'd hear if you don't
vote for trump you're essentially voting
for biden
so then my friends who like voted third
party were like i guess i voted twice
because
yeah yeah yeah because because if one
there you go you know i think that's an
under
under appreciated phenomenon is the
intellectual wing of the maga movement
i think there's a lot of very thoughtful
people that are analyzing the academic
and philosophical trends
and that they're really taking a
principled stance somebody like james
lindsey
is a great example who went through a
very public experience of coming to
grips
and understanding that in order to stand
up for what he believed was right
he needed to get in with maga and
there's a lot of people
on that edge you know that you keep
thinking are going to break this way
are going to finally see you know guys
like andrew sullivan or eric weinstein
and those guys you think that they're
just
on the cusp but they're not there's just
nowhere near sullivan just disappoints
me
all the time at this point i used to
really like that guy 15 20 years ago i
used to really sam harris
yeah it's it's it's so crazy that sam
harris is
famous for his articulate
uh assessment of radical islam and he
sits on that on bill maher
with ben affleck and he's like when we
look at
the concentric circles you can see that
51 million people is explaining how like
there
are illiberal beliefs among this
religion and i think
it's a fair point many religions have
illiberal beliefs within them but then
ben affleck just snaps and he's like
it's racist
and then sam harris was like well i
disagree why can't we have a rational
discussion
and then the trump supporters sing you
know i'm figuratively now this really
happened a trump supporter says you're
right sam harris let's have a
conversation about trump well trump is
awful
he's a racist it's like you're supposed
to be smart dude right supposed to be
calm and rational right instead he
tweets all this ridiculous you know
nonsense about trump
so so anyway back to the point the
democrats
i can prove with one simple fact they
survive
only on the low information voter dude
and you know what that fact is
they tried they pushed for 16 year olds
to vote yes
that's it there's listen you can argue
that
16 year olds should have the right to
vote fine but you're not going to tell
me that a 16 year old is a high
information voter
there may be a small group of what what
did jen call them indigo children
who are just gifted and and and no in
their proges they exist
very very smart young people but
politics
there's so much you have to learn and
experience through life to truly
empathize and understand
it's possible to be a very smart young
person and have understood that
maybe you know you spent your your
formative years working and traveling so
you got a bigger dose of reality than
the average person
a lot of these kids grow up
institutionalized and never see the
world even after 22 graduate from
college they still never left their
hometown
yeah so many of the kids in this country
haven't left the
six square block radius of their house
or their apartment in the city that they
live in and the democrats plan is
we should get them to vote why because
low information voters
are dancing behind the pied piper as
they lead them to the ocean
they're going dude we'll give you all
this free stuff come you know you know
what i always thought it was really
funny did he just call them rats
what yeah kind of sure i guess
uh it was an analogy i wasn't trying to
insult them uh i wasn't trying to insult
them as rats i was trying to insult
them right yeah so uh but listen listen
lemmings when i was when i was younger i
thought about something interesting
because i met a lot of people who would
tell me
that they were you know republicans
because they were fiscally conservative
but they didn't agree with republicans
on social issues and i'm like right
this is kind of like the libertarians
were right but then i thought about a
lot of the arguments about personal
responsibility
and the democrats arguments for welfare
benefits
free you know free free health care free
college free this free that
and i'm like man it really does sound
like you've got two parents
and your dad is saying look son if you
wanna
buy candy you gotta go work to get the
money to buy the candy with and the
mom's going just give him the candy dear
it's okay honey and then gives the candy
which one is the kid gonna pick
freak andy yeah but you know you make an
interesting uh comparison there
it in raising a child having a mom who's
going to coddle you and give you stuff
and a dad that's going to tell you to
take risks and and tough love
that's a great combination yes that
produces a healthy child
but not a healthy nation but that's
becoming rarer
and rarer and then we have a lot of
people being shipped in to be the
nannies and the nannies are like let's
just put the kid in front of the tv
or give him a screen and as you said
kids sometimes don't even leave the six
block radius i would say their eyes
don't even leave the screen
for more than the entire day that
they're up and awake
i just got a really good idea for a skit
it's two politicians
one politician is you know he's like
gotta he's got he's not wearing a tie
it's you know it's unbuttoned he's
really relaxed his sleeves you know he's
or folded up or whatever and
and he's like listen we're going to get
this country back on track
but it's going to take hard work from
all of us and we're going to pitch in
we're going to strengthen our community
and together we will lead this nation
anew
crickets and then it goes to the next
guy and he's dangling keys he
and they're going yeah they're cheering
and clapping and celebrating
and then it's like landslide and it's a
picture of him holding keys and dangling
i think that's a meme
there that i saw a couple times but
again if you're paying attention i'm
seeing
a lot of people who are in politics who
are in social commentary
becoming more and more worried because
it definitely seems like the
low information voters the
disenfranchised the angry
are becoming bigger and bigger i don't
know if that's just something that we're
seeing because of the social media lens
that we have
but it definitely seems like there are
more people who are not in the know
than the people who are in the know well
you know it used to be that the people
were i hate this low information voter
it's insulting i like the phrase uh
rationally
ignorant right the the rationally
ignorant uh used to just be that
rationally ignorant but now through
casual
interaction through social media they're
not just rationally ignorant now they're
just like
accidentally you know what's the word
when you become id
you know an ideology where you like
ideologue yeah you come in accidental
ideologue right just through
incidental contact on social media they
were they were rationally ignorant
but now because they were posting you
know pictures of what they had for lunch
and talking to their grandma now they're
also
getting this like uh incidental
radicalization they're taught to be
experts in everything
right they are being abused yes yes they
are
yes the r and the d on the voting
ballots it's they're being manipulated
to vote for what
a feeling that they have that if the
democrat their picture they picture blue
they picture
certain things and so they just they're
they're being abused into into being
brainwashed into that to put into that
they're they're voting straight party
yeah that's that's like a form of abuse
people against someone's in sub
intellect if they don't communicate
we communicate sub-vocally we
communicate through colors we
communicate through images we
communicate through associations and
consistency
that does this doesn't bother me having
the the parties on the ballot
and and i find it as a a useful uh
conductor like you see
information if you see ron or rand paul
and you're like i love that guy
therefore i must vote for republicans
and you then you want to put something
like mitch mcconnell into office yeah
right what have i done so i don't i i
think it's
real a mind screw to to trick people
into voting a certain way well that's
the whole the whole thing you know
there's a reason why they made the
president minimum age 35
right why why can we vote for the guy
under 35 as i'm getting older and
crankier and get off my lawner
i'm thinking you know we should be
raising the voting age
and you know with skin in the game but
now i don't want to get too crazy well
so
that's what i said yesterday i said that
yesterday a couple of things we've seen
over the past couple
hundred years is that we've eroded the
nature of the republic closer towards
federalization and direct democracy
that's been a
onward trend uh a big trend so that's i
think that has
sort of changed the shape of this
country is it used to be that the states
would appoint
electors it used to be that the states
would appoint senators
and then we've slowly changed all the
rules to be like popular vote popular
vote popular vote
and now they're trying to do it once
again national popular vote
should should we if we believe in the
founding
we believe in the original principles of
the country we believe in the
constitution and all that
as a thought example if we brought the
founding fathers back today coached them
upon what was going on shouldn't we just
do what we think that they would say
what they would do what would their
reaction be
sometimes yeah because they lived in
extremely different times
and and the ideas of classical
liberalism to them were relatively
new and there were a lot of there were a
lot of mistakes that they made in fact
the declaration of independence
disparages the native americans as a spe
like par
partly the reason they wanted
independence was the crown was like
using native americans against them and
it's like
there's a lot of things true true we've
changed our views on yeah but
the the general concept of individualism
life liberty pursuit of happiness
they would look at the constitution and
be like how many amendments wow that's
fantastic because we
you know they negotiate i think the bill
of rights what was it several years
after the constitution
and the constitution was actually
several years after the articles of
confederation so
it was a law it wasn't the declaration
of independence happened and then it was
like almost what like a decade later
they're like ten years before the
constitution yeah
exactly jefferson was really down on
central banks he didn't want central
banks and
washington didn't like political parties
like that i think they were
spot on about well washington washington
believed in term limits which
should be implemented i think everywhere
within the senate and the congress and
now we're living in a time where
literally hillary clinton votes in the
electoral college and then
says that we need to abolish the
electoral college immediately just like
she did a couple days ago which is
a little mind-boggling to say the least
monsters have taken over yeah imagine if
you know we didn't have a democratic
republic and it was just rule by the
masses
i mean you can only imagine i i think we
need a uh parliamentary
hearing from the british courts to
determine whether or not the vote
for the from the founding fathers had
any legal authority uh in the first
place
you're here right probably so we should
retrograde to uh
retro seed back to the united kingdom
yes so i'm joking but just joking
when i see these uh these republican
electoral candidates cast their
procedural votes and everybody says
they're not official they're
illegitimate or whatever i'm like
the founding fathers i was reading by
this that like by what appointment or
election did they become the
representatives for the continental
congress
like it's actually random there was no
uniform policy between different states
as to who would go
and a lot of people felt they didn't
actually represent the state at all
because many people were loyalists and
were like we don't want a revolution
stop we don't want the violence
and in fact there was there's really
interesting writing about how
it you know uh uh the what was going on
the conflict of the crown was not worth
it because too many people were dying
and it was too much chaos
and it was better to just pay your taxes
and shut up a lot of what we see now for
many of these democrat cities
as the governors uh you know passed
these edict destroying everything
they're like well well no you know calm
down
actually i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
that was wrong i should say
conservatives are doing that right now
conservatives are the ones who are like
you know and i don't mean trump
supporters
or all conservatives but they're the
ones who are just like
you know the republicans who are saying
we have to vote republican for the
senate
meanwhile they won't actually fight for
anything the democrats are screaming to
have their lungs non-stop demanding
things and they get it
the republicans are just sitting there
going like uh in a minute and then sure
fine you can have whatever you want
they're not doing anything
yep so we're at that point and and the
governors just absolutely abuse
their citizens as i'm pulling up a story
i just looked at a story here randomly
on twitter
of an incident where new york city
police officers
went undercover to order food in a
restaurant
and then they arrested the restaurant
owner arrested after secretly
yes dressing up as normal citizens when
he walked in the business yes this is a
story i could send it
to you lydia if you want right now but
this is what's uh uh in new york city
just another
uh the story just broke 40 minutes ago
but this is another just a greatest
example
shred on me yeah all it does
is i sent you the story all it does is
tread what what what is the flag from
the left the fist crushing the snake
saying we will tread
yeah congratulations you elected these
people they had a banner like that
yes i know it's the fist crushing the
snake and what's really funny it's very
similar to a nazi propaganda of the fist
squeezing the snake would you be
interested in starting a new political
party the maga party
the mag apart well i don't think i would
want to start the maga party but i
certainly think that there are
opportunities for new political
organizations it's happened before we've
seen it happen in the united states
there's precedent
there's no reason why it couldn't happen
today i'm sure back then they said it
shouldn't happen then either
trump trump supporters should just do it
you're not getting what you want from
the republican party
the republican party has is not going to
fight for you hasn't fought for you and
that's why trump
happened trump came about because the
republicans weren't serving the american
people the way they wanted them to
indeed and so trump gets elected and now
once these
establishment cronies get their first
chance they're like
here's the thing a political party could
change very very quickly because what
we're talking about is the maga
network the network is what launched
trump into office
over the objections of all the gop
establishments still to this day
and that network still exists and that
network still wants action and with
proper alignment a plausible promise
that networks
you know direction could be just pointed
in a different way and if you look at
american history
political parties realign all the time
and have
uh throughout the beginning of the us
constitution and we are kind of seeing
that happening
right now where a lot of the values of
the left and even in
in the year 2000 are becoming the values
of the right which is becoming anti-war
pro-free speech uh which which is
something that we never thought it would
be something that
republicans would be kind of
representing or not republicans people
on the right which i think is immoral
but here's here's the problem when i
when we have these guests on the show
who are like in their 20s and they're
democrats who voted for biden
they were they were they were children
when occupy wall street was happening
they were they were they were toddlers
when george w
bush was starting these wars they
weren't alive many of them
when 9 11 happened or they were babies
or you know
completely that's why i brought 911 up
here so listen yeah i was at occupy wall
street louis at occupy wall street
and you were at occupy wall street we we
all sort of experienced this and were
you know
a bit older than these younger guys we
are now finding ourselves
as you know like you jack democrat
democrat to deplorable
me as you know milkto centrist but i did
vote for trump because i think it was
the right choice
and then these younger people who didn't
experience the obama administration to
the full effects
don't know anything about it so the left
is courting
young people who are i'm going to say it
low information
they don't know anything about this and
they're being exploited
then the only alternative for people
like us is we need an alternative so we
go to the republicans and that creates a
cycle
where the the country always veers left
always and it won't stop that's a
problem
there needs to be a point where we have
principled conservatism that stays where
it is
and then principled sort of more i don't
want to say leftism but maybe
social liberalism or some left-leaning
policies and a real negotiation on how
far is too far in either direction it
doesn't happen it's just always going to
the left
the republicans don't fight for anything
i don't know if you heard what michael
malus said he made a really good point i
keep bringing it up but i have to
when obama got his way and said you are
legally obligated to buy health
insurance or pay a fine
where are the republicans to say okay
and we'll negotiate there
we will absolutely give you your
individual mandate and we want one of
our own
everyone must buy a gun otherwise pay a
fine
where is the inversion where is the
other side of that argument given the
take
yeah there's none it's republicans going
we think you should slow down
and they say no and then the problem can
say slow down and then
a year goes by and republicans are like
okay fine you can have it yeah there's
nothing
resisting so here we are you know i grew
up uh punk rock skateboarder
and uh voted for trump and you were a
democrat vote over trump and why
because they changed on social issues i
think that's that's fine you know
progress on social issues and civil
liberties and stuff
but if it's changing the economic policy
in a way that's destroying everything
we've got a serious problem
and that's what's basically happening
it's it's a constant quest for power
where you have one side that demands it
and takes it and another side the
republicans who are just like
basically holding a rope and being
dragged along the way
nine million people change their vote
from obama to trump in 2016.
i wonder if that number grew
significantly in this last election it
just doesn't seem to have been enough
don't forget that he only won in 2016
77 000 votes across three states and
just a handful of counties really made
the difference how do you feel about a
peaceful divorce
i'm all for it but i'm not let's let me
just a lot of people are man let me just
qualify this
i'm all for it in like a brainstorming
session we'd have to get into some real
brass tacks to actually make it work
but as i was driving up here today i was
thinking how could we actually get
a peaceful sorting and one way i thought
about doing that
is maybe if we eliminate and this is all
pie in the sky nonsense right
but maybe we eliminate the federal
income tax and you put all the social
welfare stuff on the states
then people can just vote you'd be like
i want to live in a high tax high social
welfare state
and you go there and you pay your taxes
everybody gets their social welfare
great
i want to live in a low state low social
welfare or low tax
i'm gonna go move there and really make
it about money
and then let's just see what happens i
mean it kinda is that way
is it yeah i mean you could i mean
federal income tax is pretty big dude
sure sure i know but you're basically
saying cut taxes no obviously
i'm saying like shift shift the
structure around so that people can make
choices within this within this
structure right now but look
like we're gonna buy a big old farmland
in the middle of west virginia yeah
specifically because you can do things
in west virginia you can't do other
places yep you can just like
point a gun and shoot it yeah i know i'm
kidding i'm kidding but the federal
income tax could also go up to 80
percent you're still living in west
virginia
right right right and the anti-gun laws
that biden's going to be passing are
going to be affecting everything well
literally that's when i think we're at
we're
dangerously close to the point where
even liberals
brains are going to explode because you
can only sit sit back for so long so
listen
i'm going to pull these stories we got
this story this one luke just mentioned
undercover cops order food then arrest
bar owner for defying nyc indoor dining
rules
look at this smug disgusting despicable
man
cuomo he literally killed six
thousand people by putting sick covet
patients in nursing homes
he is in my opinion a murderer who set
policies forth
that they should have known that i can't
imagine they didn't know at the very
least
fine i'll tone it down a little bit he's
responsible for the negligent homicide
of 6 000 elderly folks by putting covet
patients in these buildings now what is
he doing
his police oath breakers new york police
officers
arrested a bar owner for violating
covert restrictions after executing a
sting
in which they ordered food from the
restaurant ap reported
the new york city sheriff's deputies
entered mack's public house in staten
island new york and ordered 40
of the food and beverages according to a
sheriff's office press release
congratulations guys
you got them selling that food that's
contraband in new york city the
sheriff's officers are wannabe cops mark
fonte a lawyer who represents the bar
told the staten island advance this is
what happens when little people get a
little power
each one of them will have to answer to
a federal judge oath
breakers praetorian guard for
unconstitutional edict that was never
passed
at a certain point the state legislators
stopped saying we're going to pass laws
and it's all relatively recent
check this one out this is probably the
most insane thing i've seen in a long
time did you hear this
cuomo signs bill banning the sale of
confederate flags on new york state
grounds
and other hate symbols clearly
admittedly according to cuomo in
violation of the first amendment
probably new york's constitution as well
doesn't care they just do it and do the
police care
nah so you know what at this point look
i i moved out of these places
you got antifa setting up their
autonomous zones quite literally don't
care
have it have at it bro i don't care and
i'll tell you this
i'll take it give them new york when we
saw these riots
i was very much like dude defunding an
abode in the place is stupid you know
why
because you need in a civilized society
and this is like a lot of intellectual
dark webs this is brett weinstein said
police need to be able to make arrests
someone is going to commit a crime and
we need a system by which they can
reasonably identify somebody arrest them
and bring them in
and so we have these laws it makes sense
i am not an anarchist
luke maybe you disagree michael malus
disagrees but i think
police aside from a lot of the the dumb
stuff you know the quotas fines or
whatever
we need to be able to call a cop and say
you are the essential first layer of
defense for when a crime is committed i
report it to you as an official
you know arbiter you're neutral you're
not you know you know in many cases
then it goes to the courts the da's and
that's the process we have i respect
that in a lot of ways
but right now i don't care anymore i
left these places
because these cops have no no allegiance
to the law to the constitution
they are criminals at this point well
beyond my tolerance level
let me just say one more thing when when
michael mouse was on the show and he
mentioned
that in new york city we have a
constitutional right to bear arms but
these cops
don't let him they are criminals and for
me that's not my threshold i see his
point you know what i kind of agree with
him now now
when i see this stuff the cops are
arresting a dude for selling food
these people are despotic they are
psychopaths
and you know what man i i just if if if
if i was given the powers of the emperor
i'd be like those officers badges
removed pensions revoked
exile away gone you are a criminal as
far as i can tell i won't lock them up
but get out of here
well tim one thing you have to
understand these police officers are
political
they're not apolitical they're very
political when they're following through
on these decrees that haven't even been
officially passed by the kind of rule of
law that everyone accepts everyone to go
by
there's even official case law where the
new york city police department argued
that they don't
have to do anything they don't have to
help anyone during a moment
that was you felt like you interviewed
the guy yeah the cops like watched a do
get stabbed
yes there was a mass murderer running
around joe luzito
a guy who looked very similar to you i
don't know if you know about the story
of joe lozito
amazing human being this random guy
starts trying to kill people on the
subway he intervenes
he gets stabbed up he takes him down the
police officers are literally
standing there right next to him
watching him as he's getting stabbed in
his skull with a huge butcher knife
right then as he's subdued by joe as the
police officers are literally
watching the whole time this whole
interrocation with guns
with batons not doing anything literally
they take joe off put the suspect in
handcuffs
and they wait there for a long time joe
wakes up in the hospital almost
lost his life was an inch away from
losing his life because of the blood
loss because of the time it took
the nypd to figure out what was going on
the train was in the middle of the
tracks and they took them
a very long time to get them to the next
track to get joe into an ambulance he
wakes up and he has
the mayor there congratulating these
police officers who are deemed heroes of
who who saved the the innocent people
and they called
joe an innocent person joe took the nypd
to
court one for libel calling him a victim
when he's the one that took down the
purp
with the knife as the police officers
were literally standing there
and the new york city police department
argued and one successfully
that they had no duty to help serve or
protect anyone
and that's the case law on the books
right now that the police officers don't
have to do or abide by any kind of
decree to do anything for you you know
what they
they these city cops lost all of my
support
all of it you know it was bad enough
when when i called out the
the 27 cops who were guarding the black
lives matter mural
it was illegally painted in it basically
seized taxpayer dollars to paint a
political slogan to send a message to
trump which was just insane and
irresponsible
and these cops gleefully defended what
was
clearly illegal they don't care they're
breaking their oath
and i said of those cops take their
pension away strip them of everything
and kick them out
take their badges and i want to see them
look you're done you're gone
get out at this point i don't live in
these cities
okay i left i was in the philly suburbs
it was actually a fairly nice place we
had
our local department was really really
nice and uh we're now
essentially in the like nearly to the
point where officially moved away
and i was like it's insane to say defund
the police because
most police departments are not big city
police departments
big city police departments are big
massive with huge budgets like new
york's was like six billion dollars
but most apartments are not and so you
got to make sure you differentiate
between
what the left is saying when they say
defund the police well they're talking
specifically about
the big city cops right they're talking
about the places where they vote for
these people
these mayors they vote for these these
politicians these these
representatives and these governors and
then these cops get appointed
so your beef is where you live and you
know what i realized i was like you know
it's a really good point
why do i care if auntie was an
autonomous zone i'm not going to go
there i don't live there and the people
who live there vote for the politicians
and the da's who allow it to happen
they must like it so far be it from me
to tell them the way they should live
if they voted for it and it's being
allowed
more power to you auntie [ __ ]
congratulations on your autonomous zone
don't you're not going to see any
resistance for me and i'll tell you this
the cops who are there and are fighting
with them i think those cops are in the
wrong
you you can't allow this to happen the
da's
the people vote for and the cops try and
go and shut it down nah at this point
if you and oregon want as an officer are
going to shut down these businesses
by edict and and you know violate the
rights of individuals
then why should i care if the people say
this is allowed if the da says they're
allowed to do it then so
what if someone set up an autonomous
zone in your backyard
that's different you call it cops uh in
my backyard right now yeah
on private property probably not where
we are ian
and and the the laws of this current
location i think if someone came onto my
property they'd
i would not call it
you might shoot them to death but you
know ideally you'd call the cops
because they're someone's coming on
private property so that's what those
people if
bro we're in the middle of nowhere it's
pitch black outside if people are
looking on my property they're going to
be in serious trouble
it's it's not like look uh when i lived
on a farm in miami
we the only the only weapon we had was a
22 break barrel
uh pellet rifle because like we were not
gun people at the time especially me it
was like fun we were just like shooting
targets in the backyard
and one day someone jumped the six-foot
fence surrounding our property on a
five-acre plot
and there's you call the cops
congratulations they'll be here in 40
minutes
so what do we do well maybe it's not the
smartest thing to have done
but i broke the barrel and and dry fired
it bang
and the person with the light ran back
the way they came gone
if i called the police they would have
said do you have a gun
well then what do you want us to do we
can't we can't get there for 40 minutes
40 minutes
you know like where we are right now
like how long it would take no no no
that's why we are armed
and that's why i'm like i'm i'm i'm out
of philly i'm responsible for myself
if someone in philly one of the property
you know one of my properties i'm doing
something i'd call the cops and the cops
would
in most instances promptly remove them
and that's why i think
you know i'm not blanket defund the
police because
that's something they'll do they'll
resolve the issue when a guy tried
breaking into my other house
the cops showed up literally in like one
minute it was amazing
and the cop said to me if it was me i
would answer the door the shotgun
and i'm like bro we're in new jersey
it's not that easy
it's not that it's not that hard but you
know i have sympathy for the cops i
talked to a lot of cops in dc i've got a
lot of sources inside mpd and they are
always constantly telling me
how opposed they are to mayor bowser
how opposed they are to the black lives
matter stuff on the street how opposed
they are
to the uh sort of rules of engagement
that they have and the restrictions that
are put on them and
how difficult it is to check out riot
gear and like all these things that make
it even just
harder for them to do their job harder
for them to be safe etcetera there's a
constant conflict there so
and the guys that staffed the dc bro
what are they doing
hold on hold on hold on i hear you i
hear you the moment they go in
undercover and arrest a guy for serving
food is the moment i say buh-bye
i don't care what happens in your city
you guys are are attacking
innocent people at this point you you
are harassing
you are degrading and berating and
insulting
and destroying the lives of regular
people who are not hurting anybody
so you know what you're on your own but
i don't care what you're doing that's
just a couple of guys that
that could have been just a couple of
you know angry
jerks then i want to see then i want to
see all of the nypd
calling in a blue flu and saying this
crossed the line we want to enforce it
and they won't do that they won't stand
back while riots happen they'll have the
little slow down
as of course riots are hitting fifth
avenue and they won't do anything then
which they did
and leaving people helpless as of course
people are just literally running down
the street taking whatever they want
that's literally what happened there was
police officers during
riots in new york city that were on the
same block just standing by
kicking rocks not doing anything fox
news was there two o'clock in the
morning filming them be like
i don't know what's going on this huge
shock on this fox news reporter's face
i can't believe the cops are just
standing there and these guys are just
running into all these stores and taking
whatever they
what do you think was going to happen
they did nothing yes during the riots
exactly and then the moment cuomo says
by decree
your life is destroyed the police went
with
pleasure yeah we're going to go i'm
going to
stick up for my dc mpd guys i think it's
different in new york
you know just that's just the vibe that
i get from the cops in dc and what i
have
that's what i observe on the street and
as a citizen in dc and that's what i was
trying to say just a moment ago
like i'm not gonna blanket my small town
cops outside of the philly area
because they were really awesome they
did a great job but when you look at new
york city
why should i care yeah they defunded the
cops a billion dollars
good i don't care these cops they they
go undercover and sting
a bar for serving food but what about
during the riots
terrible yeah just the worst possible
and and so i look at
i look at uh portland and they got this
new
you know red house autonomous zone
they're like booby traps and stuff
and i'm just like you know what at this
point why should i support any of these
guys in these cities they locked down
oregon
they shut down these businesses and when
the riots were going on
many of the cops when they were told not
to interact with the federal police they
said okay
they're like we wish we could help bro
you're a human being you can make a
choice
nothing's stopping you from making a
choice imagine if like
you look at any comic book hero look at
the you know the marvel movie civil war
imagine if the heroes were all like oh
gosh darn it they told us we couldn't go
and fight the bad guy oh well and they
just didn't
you know you bring up a good point with
your with your joke
it does take a superhero to resist
to say no to a direct order to maybe
perhaps
violate what who knows what they believe
the law is what their education level is
on these decrees versus legislation
whatever it takes a hero
to stand alone in a circumstance like
i'm not
saying it justifies doing the sting
listen listen i'm just saying like it
does take especially
we should be honest about this a lot of
officers are self-serving a lot of
officers when they're cho
they're given a choice hey do you want
to have a paycheck for your family
or you want to not have a paycheck for
your family they're going to make the
decision that's going to work out for
them best
and this is why we have them doing
absurd things like dressing up
as undercover average civilians and they
and
this is not the first time something
like this has happened there was
undercover officers dressing up as
homeless people
so they could get people for uh you know
eating yeah
for giving money in some institutions
and in some places and also speeding
one last pushback humans in every
industry do things that hurt other
humans
it's not just the cops well we should
have made make people aware of that
because people are under this illusion
that they're there to protect and serve
get rid of their slogans
and say i am obeying my overlord that's
a more accurate statement here's here's
the simple way i'll break it down
when there are innocent people having
their businesses destroyed
you did nothing yes i think the police
do a good job when they stand up and
they defend the city and they try to
maintain order the best of their
abilities
it's a very difficult position to be in
and that's why i say when antifa
is calling for defining the police while
burning everything down like y'all are
nuts
but then what happens when after you've
said thank you all for doing a good job
he says
shut your goddamn mouth and cracks you
in the mouth of the truncheon and then
he personally throws the brick through
your window now i'm like bro you're
antifa
these cops going to a guy's business and
shutting it down that's exactly what
antifa was doing that i was complaining
about
the problem is when an individual
regardless of who they are where they
align
destroy the livelihood of the innocent
and the cops are doing that now so as
far as i'm concerned
they're mud in new york city sorry
they're the same thing as antifa was
going around rioting the cops are doing
the same thing now
so who do we get the feds is trump going
to send in somebody he should
he probably could but he's not gonna do
anything like that and he hasn't done
anything like that
and who else is gonna do it nobody so so
listen i wanna i wanna reference this
one more time
cuomo banned the sale of confederate
flags clearly in violation of the
constitution i don't
confederate flag i don't care for that
stuff but how are you going to be like
that constitution thing
screw off i don't care we're going to
pass the law
and then there's that viral video i
think it was out of california where you
had the it was a knicks greek i think it
was yes and the health inspector
the door was open they're like your door
is open so that's all that matters
you're getting a fine
that's just the law sir and he goes what
law no law was ever passed
there was no vote there was nothing it
was just edict from some guy
we don't care sir these people are
psychopaths
and we are in serious trouble because
we're at a point now where there's no
cohesive culture
where people are like we are a nation of
laws and we abide by the constitution
we're now a nation of people being like
i don't know just you know i was told to
do it yep and the bureaucrats that were
enforcing these laws that you were
specifically mentioning at that
restaurant
were even screamed at by average
civilians walking by saying
why aren't you at costco why aren't you
at walmart
why are the big multinational
corporations allowed to exist
meanwhile small independent businesses
are getting squashed out
as these plutocrats are literally
obsessing about a great reset
and the redefinition of capitalism that
of course will empower them with even
more
authority more regulations more rules
and more bull crap that will only happen
because these officers
are deciding to choose to listen to
someone like andrew como and if they
decided to have a backbone some of them
are
there's a few sheriffs from new york
that decided and said no
and of course what did andrew como did
he what did he said he said that they're
dictators
because they're choosing not to follow
his own decrees and this is the person
by the way
that was also seriously accused of
abusing a female counterpart which again
a lot of people in the mainstream media
aren't talking about especially cnn
msnbc but most importantly
joe biden is considering this man that
just
banned the the confederate flag like
like in new york we have so many
problems we have so many issues we have
to deal with
but this man's main objective is to ban
a symbol that no one really cares about
in new york anyway
that does nothing just virtual signal to
people how much of an authoritarian he
is
this man might be the next attorney
general of the united states
imagine the chaos the pain and suffering
that he will cause when he has more
power
underneath him and more willing servants
more obeyers
that of course will follow up every one
of his orders without even
thinking about it andrew cuomo
instructed sick
uh coveted patients into nursing homes
killing about six thousand meanwhile
there was hospitals
all over new york city there was a
javits center was empty
we had a whole huge naval ship brought
in that was an entire hospital central
park
field hospital in music nothing and then
sick elderly
sent back this is why i will say in my
opinion
the only explanation is that cuomo did
it on purpose
he was laughing and smiling and he said
we got coveted patients
put them in the nursing homes but sir
the javits center is only at 30 capacity
i said put them in the nursing homes yes
sir i'll do whatever you say cause i'm a
boot licker adhesive
the son of a gun won an emmy he won an
emmy for his
work regarding cope and then wrote a
book and then he wrote a book
so congratulating himself about what a
great job he did meanwhile he had the
highest death record than i think
anywhere else in the united
states yeah are you freaking kidding me
and this is going to be the next
attorney general of the united states
who's the girl what do you mean
what do you mean by that's that's that's
number one
he's he that's the number one candidate
is daddy
because mario cuomo he's got the name
he's got a frown on his face
let me let me let me let me let's hold
on a second jack yes you saw what the
proud boys were doing
in dc in dc last weekend looked a whole
lot like antifa to me
oh so we're going to start off like that
are trying to are we
i'm not a proud boy and i'm not a proud
here to carry any water for them
whatsoever but i saw them talk about it
i saw them tearing down banners
yeah lighting them on fire yeah and i've
seen antifa stealing flags and lighting
them on fire yeah and i don't i think
stealing someone's private property and
destroying it is wrong okay
i think if you want if you want to have
a symbol of your political belief you're
allowed to do it we have to respect
these boundaries
uh i agree with almost everything of
what you said there except for
the last one but hold on the point of
this is not for me to rag on the proud
boys this is actually me defending the
proud boys okay
when they do which is not even as bad as
antifa because antifa attacks innocent
regular people
and threatens innocent regular people
now it was wrong because
the the churches that the proud the
banners off of were innocent
but it's not it's not to the same scale
of antifa
you know chasing people down the street
and beating them
the proud boys are facing hate crime
charges hate crime charges possible
possible and and wasn't it the proud
boys who got they were the ones who got
stabbed proud boys got stabbed yeah
critical condition
three of them got stabbed in an
altercation it's unclear as to
who was uh who provoked the
authentication in the first
and the daily mail admitted the knife
from the photo
so listen here's the first point i want
to make starting this off and then we'll
carry on
the reason i bring this up in the
context of our previous conversation yes
sir
antifa can go around and doing it for
years yes the proud boys go and do
something not even
to the same degree but similar and
immediately the cops are like hate crime
investigation we're taking these guys
down okay so
i have guys on the inside of mpd we've
been talking about this they've been
talking to me i've been
on this story thinking about it and
first things first
is if you burn a black lives matter
banner that's not a crime right if you
print up a sign that looks exactly like
all the other signs
and you take it out in the street and
you burn it no problem if you find a
black lives
matter banner on the ground and you pick
it up and you burn it
no problem if you
if you happen to be in possession of it
and you burn it no problem the only
time that it's a problem is if you if
you if you steal it
right and so i don't know that there was
they don't have any uh
direct video evidence maybe they weren't
actually saying that there was
confirmed theft first so theft needs to
come before destruction of
private property and then you have to
have like hateful intent and bias and
whatever so
what happens is they they saw the crime
of the burning they wanted to prosecute
it goes to the twitter handle it's the
the pete the police
twitter handle is the one that decides
how to characterize it so i'm sure
that's a political decision right
and then once it's characterized as a
hate or biased crime then it goes to
some sort of liaison unit
whose job it is for them to go and
investigate and i have a feeling it will
get lost
somewhere in there first of all they
haven't been able to confirm or convict
that they were theft
in the first place and it's totally
perfectly legal to take a black lives
matter banner
burn it whatever now so a lot of a lot
of these guys that were surrounding it
there's no crime for them because as far
as they knew someone had a banner and
they burned it correct
yeah correct the only time it would be a
crime is if somebody was
witnessed and saw them it was confirmed
that they stole it from another
even though it has the church's logo on
it if they found it on the street and
burned it's still not a crime yeah
uh but the interesting thing is you're
right about the hate crime it's like
political black lives matter is such an
exquisitely crafted phrase
that it is at once a political movement
it's at once
a statement of some sort fact and it's
it wants something that tugs on your
heartstrings about being
racist or not but the truth is is it
means different things to different
people
when the church puts it up on their i'm
sure they really mean like black lives
matter we should just
let's not have black people it's a
church yeah it's a church that doesn't
that doesn't mean that they're going to
be acting in the right way all the time
of course any religious organization
that's not justification for them uh but
it is clearly a political movement right
it's clearly
and like has has funding with billions
of dollars and they have initiatives and
they have a platform
six billion ten point six billion
dollars and and the juicy delicious part
is watching the blm groups
fight about that money there's 10.6
there's a big billion dollars
yep lydia found that one there's the
schism there's a schism in the blm
chapters with the national and whatever
they're fighting over the money
that you know and it's just cracks me up
to see them just going down the normal
route
but it's not a hate crime to burn a
donkey
or an elephant even the flag the reason
i bring this up
is for one yes i want to be critical of
the proud boys did to a certain degree
but also defend them in this in in the
sense that if
the da's allowed us if the media allows
this for antifa
then how could they come out with this
double standard it just shows you
the media clearly doesn't represent the
people it's it's it's all ideological
and that brings me back to some of the
earlier stuff we were talking about the
election
the numbers none of it matters it just
matters what people choose to believe
and what to fight for
so when when i look at these uh uh
i'll just put i'll be more general so i
don't single anybody out
there are too many instances where
conservatives
were say defying lockdown and getting
arrested
and they were complying and not
resisting and there are too many
instances where the left
literally beat the cops and then get
their charges dropped
yeah that's how extreme the disparity is
between the left and the right yeah that
antifa for this whole year
you know the chas this is amazing i
learned this today you know chaz was
never cleared out
we thought the the the capital
autonomous zone was gone right
no they stayed in the cal anderson park
until now
with tents with barricades and
everything i did not know that nobody
cared
because the city said we got rid of it
and the main area the streets were
opened up but the park itself remained
occupied
by these far leftists and it just sort
of disappeared that was going on forever
and in the meantime we've had many
stories of people defying lockdown
and the nypd shows up and arrests them
how incredible is that
at the far left can riot they can they
can destroy things they can
i'll tell you this we got a story where
a guy
has a business was called rio's ribs and
the neighboring building was burnt down
it caused damage to like the greater
structure i guess or to the neighboring
buildings
and so he gave an interview where he was
disparaging the rioters
so the next day on surveillance on
security footage you can watch this they
released the video just the other day
a guy burns the man's business to the
ground
don't you dare speak up against us says
this lunatic and so they threw
burning trash and then he opens the gate
to go back in and look and make sure the
fire's catching
and that's what happens with the far
left and then what do we see the
district attorneys in these places
cut them loose well okay you know what
that's why i'm at the point where i'm
like i don't care about your city the
arsonist's
face was blurred yeah yeah in an actual
news
i'm like who are they protecting like
are they trying to catch this person do
they want to know who actually
did this who's actually burning down
people's buildings for political reasons
in these places the far left is
protected they can literally burn it
down and the media is like cover their
face because we don't want to get in
there and we have to understand george
soros is financing a lot of these
attorney generals and going into local
towns and smaller cities and saying you
know what we're going to give them
millions of dollars let's be specific
the what is it called the open society
foundation yes that provides grants to
nonprofits
who then fund and they've financed
a lot of different ones that are
creating and sowing havoc
in big cities like san francisco the the
san francisco attorney general is now
the los angeles attorney general and
that's why a lot of people are saying
what we saw in san francisco with that
entire mess i remember
even a few months ago walking down the
street in san francisco
covering the utter madness i was doing a
random walk and talk video
and i literally saw a woman screaming
police officers hearing it and walking
the other direction
there was crap i watched the lady yeah i
watched the lady
walk into the middle of the street and
she was like big fat lady
and just dropped trout right there in
the middle of the street just go at it
and i was like
whoa dude yeah i wasn't even looking for
it i was literally
at the capitol and you just see a whole
bunch of people all around it
shooting up urinating crapping and and
just
totally obviously it seems like a zombie
world out there and this is because of
these attorney generals
now los angeles has the same attorney
general as they did in san francisco
same guy supported by soros and a lot of
people are expecting the same thing to
happen as he's making
these similar kind of protocols let me
tie these ideas together real quick when
i see
antifa now start acting a fool targeting
innocent businesses i'll be mad but if i
see far leftists setting autonomous
zones
don't care because i see these cops
abusing regular people
and attacking the innocent not all cops
but these place in these places and i'll
tell you this
there's uh there's a meme that goes
around from the left they say it's
really funny
if you have 1300 good cops and 12
you have 1312 cops 1300 are really good
people
who stand by the law in the constitution
but 12 of them are criminals who keep
breaking the law
and that 1300 doesn't say anything to
stop the criminals
then you have 1 312 bad cops that's the
meme you know why
one three one two a cab all cops are bad
uh
i don't know i don't agree with that but
in new york city specifically
if these cops know it's happening and
they keep doing that job
without protest without standing up to
defend the people of that city
then i think they're just they're not
cops it's the praetorian guard for the
emperor
for the empire state that's cuomo cuomo
is passing edict he sits there and he
goes i can do whatever i want churches
gone symbols i don't like gone
decision goes against them irrelevant
i'll just make a new one and the cops go
hey we don't care what skoda says we
don't care what the constitution says
we just want that sweet sweet scrilla
from our emperor
i think that i agree with that i think i
agree with the 1312 thing not
to put it that way but i think that if
you have 1300 cops who are watching 12
cops
do bad things and do nothing to stop it
what do you have to say for the other
1300 cops
why are you not stepping in why are you
not speaking up you see what's happening
and you do nothing
like what what kind of mindset is in
these police departments that they think
it's okay that they just let this
happen let's break it down you know to
get more to the heart of the principle
when i see black lives matter
complaining about innocent people dying
completely
sympathize i empathize i don't like that
that's a violation of every
constitutional right to take someone's
life
but in many of these circumstances
they're it's unclear
it's it's not clear-cut that the cop was
just like i'm gonna kill this man
a lot of it a lot of times it's like a
very serious conflict and we have a
political debate we want to know what's
going to happen
george floyd most of us who came out
when that story came out we were like
dude that's wrong we don't like what we
saw
and then later we learned a bunch of new
details and you're like ah see things
change
but it's pretty clear-cut when a cop
dresses up in civilian clothes and then
arrests a restaurant
during an economic crisis where people
are going homeless
where they're expecting hundreds of
millions to starve and the cops are just
stomping
people into the ground that is clear-cut
no political debate
and there's record homelessness now in
new york city and there was an article
highlighting some of the pictures of
people living on the streets if you want
to talk about
unsanitary health conditions that's it
right there there's people with scabs
and scavies and all these kind of
horrible illnesses because they have
nowhere else to go that are literally
i mean all the all the housing that they
provide for them a lot of it is filled
up there's an argument that some people
make that the homeless people don't want
to go to some of these housing but
the the housing is getting filled up
because of the horrible economic
situation that has been created by the
government
here's what we want to know the best
part about all this in seattle
uh in washington and in oregon where
they're having these lockdowns like many
other places
and the police are enforcing it well
look the cdc
said right the cdc was like you got to
lock down okay the cdc also said
homeless encampments must remain
it's safer to let them stay than to
clear them out
at the same time that the police are
saying we gotta follow the cdc orders
and shut down your business
sorry they're turning around and
clearing out homeless encampments in
defiance of the cdc
you can't have it both ways either
you're enforcing the safety of the
people
because of the pandemic or you're just
crushing the week
i think this is a good time for me to
pitch a movie that i'm in coming up
lauren southern movie crossfire covers
all of these issues in-depthly and it's
very even-handed and fair and honest and
it really takes
a good hard look at the perspective of
the police officers
the black lives matter folks it goes in
depth on antifa
it really does discuss some of these
contradictions and where do your
loyalties lie
and what's it like you know being a guy
that does good most of the time but then
witnesses something that is illegal or
wrong
it's very well done there's a lot of
good people in it elijah
schaefer is in it and mike cernovich and
jack and a few others
it's well worth the the view you should
check it out
wasn't there like an excerpt talking
about the dangers of being a police
officer
but isn't there like a statistic that as
far as as far as employment police
officers are ranked
what is it 13th or i think even lower on
the
on the ranking of of deadliest jobs but
but i disagree with that
you know because you got to understand
the difference in the danger from being
like a petroleum engineer and being a
cop
a petroleum engineer it's like you do
everything right and sometimes there's a
faulty air and something blows and then
you get knocked into the ocean or
whatever
being a cop it's like you're ever you
don't know which person is gonna be the
person who's scared and wants to flee or
is a warrant so they're gonna pull a gun
well i'm not i'm not making you know
that
kind of argument that it's you know
totally a safe and wonderful amazing job
as a police officer we have to
understand the other side of it because
they are dealing with the worst elements
of our society and if you're around that
every day that's going to affect your
psyche
and that's why with most police officers
we see a higher rate of spousal abuse
and also substance abuse than we do with
any other profession out there since of
course
i think there is something to say about
people being affected by their
environment
correlation correlation it could be that
people who are prone to drug abuse and
spousal abuse
like to take risks like adrenaline like
being violent so they end up being cops
you don't know you don't know but i will
say that you're right you're out the
movie does address this very issue
talks about ptsd among the people so uh
what you're saying is that
all cops are drug addicts exactly right
and i said civil war
let's go uh but it's really worth it
because it really scooted downy uh also
and john detroit who worked on
um uh hoax the with mike cernovich they
they did the direction in the producing
it's fantastic and really well thought
out so check it out crossfire
you know these uh this past year has
really made me just uh
a very personal responsibility person
and
much more libertarian very very
libertarian two things happen
you got older and a little bit uh you
know a little bit more
to conserve let's say i don't think
getting older
played a role in it i think it was
earlier this year i was like no guns
yeah yeah it was the riots the riots the
riots and the cops standing down in many
instances and i was like wow
i can't rely on these police officers
anymore what's what good are they
yeah but in these big cities i said
these people are attacking the innocent
we need someone to stop them that's what
the cops are for
now the cops are the ones doing the boot
stomping so i'm like all right i'm out
i'm gonna go live in the mountains we're
gonna get
100 acres of farmland in the middle of
nowhere it's actually rather cheap when
you're in the middle of nowhere you
can't do much with it
no no star link no dsl no nothing it's
cheap though buy a set
internet you get does it work yeah it
does you can get like five megabits up
and down you get like you get like 20
down and five
up five up is enough buy a set so we've
we've streamed this show from satellite
before
yeah and and the quality was like 720p
and it's not
perfect but you know if i'm i'm not
we're not going to go out there to do
the show we're going to have the land
yeah right no no very first time i was
on the show back in what march or
something you know pre-lockdown
february we were talking about uh my
90-acre medieval town you can fit 50
some thousand people in a wall town on
90 acres we're gonna do a hippie a
hippie
libertarian kind of town where people
can chill and just kind of have their
own space
friends can come hang out we'll build
some skateboard stuff and it's going to
be
uh you know we got to figure out where
it's going to be because there's a
couple different things we can do
it might actually be like we build
houses
you know luke's talking about these
hippie dome houses we'll see what
happens yeah but i don't want to get too
much into the hippie dippy stuff
i'm just pointing out i got to a certain
point after watching all this stuff
where i'm like
first of all the republican party won't
fight for you
the republican party is not going to
stand up for you they you give them the
chance
and they will you know they will they
will lion king trump off the cliff
trump trump sitting there saying brother
help me and mcconnell's like no
put the claws in his hands and trump
goes flying so if you can't count on
them to fight for you defend your rights
while all this
insanity is going down then what do you
do you got to find your own space
because i'll tell you something really
funny
wasn't it wasn't it awesome how josh
hawley and bernie sanders got together
for the stimulus package
it was great right you don't think so i
don't know i mean
i feel like you're setting me up tim
josh hawley a republican
and bernie sanders progressive democrat
agreed on this 1200
stimulus package and are pushing it
trying to try to force it that's the
american people need
right i think we should have been giving
them trump bucks all year
trump bucks it's amazing to me that
while i've praised that outright
it is the democrats destroying the
economy and then the republican
siding with the democrat on how they
should solve the problem in the
temporary
instead of josh hawley coming out and
saying we're going to reopen the
economies and pass a bill
mandating federally that the
constitution be respected and these
places reopened and their jobs can come
back
instead of doing that once again it was
on the democrats terms
josh hawley came and joined the democrat
position on how to solve the problem
caused by the democrats i mean it's kind
of hard they put you into a tough spot
do you want to be the guy who's wrong
and then it leads to two million new
deaths of corona not saying
that that's what would happen but that's
what they say what will happen a good
leader would
well that's a good leader would be the
one who would say something very simply
like my friends
considering the the coronavirus has
spiked again
the first attempt at a lockdown is not
going to stop this problem
and if we stay locked down then more
people will lose their lives to suicide
to homelessness to desperation
to a lack of access to medical care bro
i'm with you 110 we must
make a hard choice and that means
compromise
here's the plan social distancing will
remain in effect nationwide
we hope the governors agree with us the
federal government has the authority to
to instruct that but we hope you all
agree
we encourage strongly masks to the best
of your abilities but
the elderly will be protected everyone
else please get on with your lives and
be
safe that's the solution or just simply
hey let's not send sick covet patients
to nursing homes i think that would be a
great start
i think less government is the answer
and i think the only way to get less
government is by having more
responsible sovereign individuals taking
responsibility into their own hands
i mean i was in new york city earlier
this year i left and i'm not looking
back and i'm never coming back ever
again i mean there are so many
unprepared that are pretty sweet though
poor what your rv is pretty sweet
it's nice but but i literally left new
york city went straight to new hampshire
and started doing survival training
courses and then
doing my own trainings of them as i was
i don't
even know from occupy wall street to the
wilderness i don't even want to say what
i've been doing in the training i
received
uh i watched luke got a rabbit
make a stew i'm kidding oh there was
i was legit impressed there was gutting
involved but that's a whole nother i
heard luke was chasing chickens around
yes he was choked chasing chickens
chasing chickens
you want to make a joke here i'm not
making any jokes
but listen it's up to everyone to to
understand the situation in front of
them and to act
responsibly stop looking for someone
else to do something for you
stop putting someone above you you are
responsible for your own life your own
choices make some smart ones stop
blaming everyone else for your problems
i agree largely with that and this
dovetails of the conversation i've been
having with the bellagio on twitter and
about
labor mobility okay so there was this
idea in free trade
that if you if you have free trade of
capital free trade of products
and free trade of people that the people
will move to where the opportunities are
and you can destroy this economy over
here and people will move over here
but what we found after wto after black
black seattle all that
what we found was is that people don't
like to move yeah labor mobility
is not as prevalent as people as the
models economic models like to say
and so the industry's left and then the
people stayed
then we then we have then we have
opioids we have
declining uh life expectancies we have
hollowed out towns etc etc now
that same phenomenon i wonder if this
low
labor mobility is going to apply
you got out of philly you got out of new
york i'm getting out of dc where am i
going to go i'm going to a jurisdiction
where i have the confidence that my
rights and the things that i want will
be
protected for as long as possible right
i would move to southwestern virginia
but it's a blue state
i don't know what's going to happen so
i'm looking at west virginia right
because i want to make sure that i go to
a county
that has a history of voting for
sheriffs that would probably say hey
you know what we're not going to enforce
these stupid laws like that you do you
and there are jurisdictions like that
that's this kind of research the
sovereignty
this individual sovereignty you have to
be that proactive i don't know are
people going to be
is this the thing that's going to make
people want to move more so
than like the town factory closing i
don't know i think that's a big deal
right
they are moving in record numbers we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
people that have left new york city and
are not coming back they're talking
about converting office spaces into
residential buildings
who's going to live in them when there's
no jobs and there's no work there the
only reason people
go through this rat infested piss
smelling hell hole that is new york
sour milk yes sour milk is also too
there's also a particular smell when
spring comes you know summer's coming
when you smell that garbage it's a weird
sense that only true new yorkers really
know
i mean i grew up there my entire life i
loved it when it was
it was you know everyone has their
little stories but right now it's not
the same
city at all and to see the the abuse
that people are going through there's
literal police officers walking around
with binoculars
there's police officers looking through
people's windows finding them for the
basic
human activities of just trying to live
so
i i don't see a lot of people surviving
thriving or if they do
they're they're going to be servants of
a state that's going to use and abuse
them at record levels like they are
right think about what's going to happen
because what did what did fauci and bill
gates say
lockdown could persist into 2022 yep or
at least some form of it
at a certain point do you think some
people are going to have no food and no
home and they're going to be really
angry and looking for it and do you
think they'll put their survival over
any law or community
it's going to be like that movie you
know what is it called daybreakers was
that what it's called
with the vampires yeah the vampires you
ever see that one so it's basically
almost everyone's society becomes a
vampire right because one by one people
start becoming vampires and they
they farm humans but they're running out
everyone's turning into a vampire
and then eventually when they start
getting desperate for for blood they go
nuts start attacking other people and
stealing it and fighting and turning
into disgusting monster creatures
and it's probably a simpler analogy
analogy just to just point out food
riots in any other revolution
but it is but it's a funny it's funny
movie uh it's a cool movie at a certain
point
when we're locked down and people are
lining up for miles in food banks which
we've already been seeing all year at a
certain point when
they're going to your business and
arresting you
saying you have no right to money to
live
people are going to snap not only that
they're going to be like i don't well
they're being arrested for not giving
their money to amazon and walmart that's
essentially
what i'm saying is in in the next year
or two with this lockdown
at a certain point someone's going to be
like i have no food i have nowhere to go
and i'm hungry
and they're going to take they don't
care because they're going to choose
survival
here's the best part we had this guy go
on msnbc this doctor you know what he
said
i i kid you not it was the craziest
thing he said if you get the covet
vaccine yeah
you can still you can still get the
virus you can still get the virus
and and we don't know if it'll actually
even if you you can still get it
and so you can't travel and you still
have to wear masks and you still social
distance
this is a misunderstanding then what's
the point of getting it
i'm not it was on msnbc i i almost think
it's like
are they lying we are being led by
idiots
the system is too complex we can't be
led by anybody do we have people in
politics that got voted in because
they're popular what i'm saying is
or the dndr what i'm saying is right now
my i think the best bet is
look land is cheap in the middle of
nowhere but what you forfeit
is access to clean running water you
know when you live in new york city
a lot more than that although by the way
drill a well
you got the best water in the world i
mean it's not it's becoming more and
more scarce and there's many predictions
that there
actually be more conflicts because of
water rights coming well so that's why
you want well water but the issue with
wells
you've got to do a lot of testing you've
got bacteria you've got mineral deposits
i've watched enough homestead rescue to
know that it is possible
i watched that show we had uranium every
single one and if you're near farmland
you can get uranium builds up build up
and that's so you need a good filtration
system you need like uv light high level
filters and stuff there's stuff
kind of stuff we're going through now
but but it is some of the best water
we got we got the water here man it is
some of the best water you'll ever
drink the water faucet is better than
city water we just turned the front lawn
into a little
farming area and again i i can't i can't
tell people this enough
learn to farm i think it's going to be
something very important that people
are going to need to learn plus it
builds a lot of good gut biome to keep
your hands in the dirt to actually work
with seeds to actually work with your
own food
that's one of the most principle amazing
things that you could do on the face of
this earth is provide for yourself
and and it sounds like manual labor for
a lot of people for a lot of
flip-flop wearing starbucks drinking
yuppies it's a nightmare
but in reality when you start doing it
you get your hands in the dirt it's one
of the most beautiful amazing feelings
that you could ever have as my good
friend joan norman who's a homesteader
in new hampshire
told me he said it reconnects you with
the low
frequency vibrations of the earth and
then that is a
healthy place to be rather than the high
frequency vibrations of social media and
your handheld device and all that
hippies
it grounding and i'm looking at ian
because i expect eating to know what
that is i used to stand barefoot in the
dirt and i would notice when it was cold
outside
it would warm me up because the warmth
from the earth would come up into my
feet and when it was hot outside it
would cool me down because the heat my
body would go into the air well there is
an energy
there's a frequency that a lot of people
talk all right you crystal way
it's true you know what hey maybe uh
west virginia isn't the right place
maybe wyoming is they have like really
bad cell service
and so cold yes so much snow
appalachia is one of the most fertile
places in america
it has low incident of natural disasters
it is near enough to large metropolitan
centers that you can get to anywhere in
the world that you want to
also the problem is with west virginia
no offense to my west virginia people
it is quite literally the oldest the
sickest
the fattest the dumbest the brokest
the least employed state in the union
so what you're saying is you know where
we can we can relocate
again the tim the tim cast company and
everything we're building yes and start
bringing revenue into these towns and
build up and and help people find jobs
and then that's assuming you stop being
amazon's number one customer
right you're gonna have to buy all man
you're gonna have to buy all that stuff
local no no no
no no as much as i can local right yeah
but bringing these tools and these
things from amazon into this area is
going to build up that area
you know agreed bringing the people is
going to bring
more business more bars more clubs you
know all that stuff will slowly start
coming and then all of a sudden people
will be voting democrat and you'll be
like i gotta get the hell out of here
yeah that's the sooner you've seen the
starbucks and the artisan donuts
get out yeah exactly but i have to yeah
i have to plug new hampshire in here
though
i have to plug new hampshire in the free
state project i love it i i i have a
love affair i mean
summers springs falls new hampshire for
me winters
florida well that was my plan but now
i'm still here depends on where you are
in the region that you decide to to
locate yourself
you have a lot of water you have no
venom mistakes you have no venomous
spiders you have a lot of land you have
a lot of territory but most importantly
you have a community
of individuals that don't like the
government love responsibility and
they're building the free state project
which is literally
a place where they set up marketplace
stores where people
sell and trade and barter it's one of
the largest places for cryptocurrency
transactions than anywhere else in
all of the united states and to me being
there spending my spring
and and summer there i absolutely loved
it and it's like 10 times the cost of
west virginia
and and they still don't have internet
the internet's pretty good there you can
get decent acreage in west virginia for
like 500 to 1500
an acre you can get 100 acres for like
50 60k
yeah if you're in like southwest or
central west virginia yeah
huge massive plots i saw one really cool
like on top of a mountain
it was crazy and then they shaved off
like the top so you could build a house
yeah dude
you could get up for the money that i'm
paying in washington dc
i was just in southwest virginia i was
at uh hot springs uh virginia
where as a matter of fact i was on
vacation tim on vacation
walking out of a restaurant without my
mask on someone runs up behind me
sir sir sir sir and i was like oh man
i'm going to get yelled at for not
having a mask on
i turn around and it's a guy in his
mid-20s or early 30s he goes
dude you're on tim pool are you jack
murphy
sorry dude i was just like on vacation
at a random place trying to get away
shout out to that guy if he's watching
right now shout out bro i think people
should know too if they don't because i
saw some people in the in the chat don't
realize that
you're you're booked as a regular like
you have a regular schedule for the show
yes it's not yeah it's not like every
other wednesday i'm here also shout out
to the dog walker in washington dc that
stopped me and my family
again just walking down the street
saying hey jack murphy senior on tim
pool
that's so great so whenever whenever we
have you on with the show does a little
better oh i think yeah
thank you people people like watching
him i appreciate it thanks guys so
in in southwest virginia for the money
that i pay in dc i could have a thousand
acres with a horse farm
horse ranch in the mountains with a
river yup same money
let's do it what's stopping you uh i
have a complicated uh divorce
situation with my kids in shared custody
otherwise dude i would have been long
gone
kids homeschooled in southwest virginia
immediately
i'm gonna find a massive plot like 100
acres somewhere
in the middle of nowhere you're telling
me to do this bigger bigger wear though
no but it's fine but a thousand acres
that's
that's a lot of money that's like a
million bucks like
three youtube videos bro
i mean and you'd also gotta find land
like next to each other otherwise you're
buying like
plots all over the place yeah finding
that's that's what i was saying like
wyoming is probably the bigger secret
it's probably like five grand for like
five thousand acres it's like some
ridiculous
like a barren wasteland dude when i was
driving through wyoming
listen listen i drove from new york to
chicago to north dakota
then off then down the the west coast of
california to los angeles
when we went through wyoming there was a
period where
we drove like 300 something miles with
no gas i was with my friend
and then i was like dude we're about to
run out of gas and there's nothing
around us anywhere it's a straight road
if we don't find a gas station we're in
serious trouble it was super cold though
it was like white out half the time
couldn't see and i'm i was driving i
think a honda civic ridiculous car to be
driving through this terrain
there was one point where the ground was
all ice and i was just like sliding
every few seconds and i was like we're
gonna die this is great
but anyway great we're down to probably
like the tiny like it's like it's on e
and i'm like we've probably got 20 30
miles
and we drive in the honda civic we drive
past this building
it's a little tiny farm house looking
shack or whatever
and i don't think twice my friend goes a
gas pump and i was like what and i'd
look back as we drive past it
two little gas pumps no signs nothing i
slam the brakes on i do a u-turn i go
back
and i walk up to the door there's no
signs and i knock and i look
and through the window i can see it was
a store and i'm like get out of here
and i walk in as a little store and
there's a guy sitting there with a
little dog and i was like hey
you you sell gas and he goes yep and i
was like can i pump gas like yep
i was like 25 a gallon sir
no it was it was not that expensive but
i was like there was no sign
i swear we were that's how crazy it was
and the best part was my phone didn't
work at all
it was something called i think it's
called union cellular i think it was a
years ago
but now they probably have better
selling saw structure uh a long
infrastructure along like certain roads
but man maybe that's the big secret
according to i think it was animated x
nobody lives there anyway do you know
anybody who lives there or who's from
there
fewer people live in wyoming than in the
city of washington dc i believe
something something
yeah yeah yeah why dc's got like a
million well i'm thinking dc dropper
which is like seven hundred thousand
it's like that right there's a few
people in wyoming yeah yeah uh wyoming
is like i think 535 000. there you go
that means you can probably buy a whole
lot of land and do a whole lot of
whatever you want
china's doing it yeah there's i saw an
article about that chinese guy that
bought land in texas
and he built a uh airstrip and he's been
like flying people in on this airstrip
and i read it it said 200 something
something land airstrip i was like
oh 200 acres that's a lot no and i went
back and read it again
200 square miles yeah this chinese guy
this chinese uh maybe there was some
affiliation with the wrong people
just acquiring mass land in texas 200
square miles that's happening
nebraska might be pretty good but you
know i think the thing is
when you're when you're closer to the
east coast like west virginia it's not
that cold not a whole lot of snow
it's it's like easier but it can get hot
in the summer
you know so it depends you want to be in
you live in the mountains middle america
it's probably harder to float
flooded pretty hard too and they got
tornadoes but if you if you buy land in
nebraska you can certainly grow corn
and then live off of corn you'd be a
corn person yeah they love their corn
hey you said something about amazon
earlier
what about it do we have to stop using
it yes
i'm obsessed with amazon i love amazon
they get it here the next day
two days later the amazon microchip is
in your brain already
you can buy almost everything on amazon
do you don't want to stop using it
like i've given over to the borg or
something it's awfully convenient bro
it's not just that it's um you know when
we when i was living in the philly area
it was really easy to be like let's go
to this store or that store to buy what
we need
now we're in the middle of nowhere there
is no that store that we need it doesn't
exist now you would have taken a
three-hour trip into the city once a
month to get you
going to town to get the things out i
tell you the mail so the way it works
when you live in the middle of nowhere
is that amazon delivers your items to
the post office not to your house
and then the post office delivers your
amazon packages most of the time
and boy are they salty with us i bet you
better tip your postman buddy
okay can you do that of course yeah yeah
i just tipped my trash guys today yeah
and i'll get the mailman
you should you should especially tip a
regular mail i didn't know you were
allowed to give them money
or whatever i don't want you you're like
supposed to in new york city like uh
you're you're mailman and your garbage
man really yeah your mailman
that's what a federal job you're giving
them cash that's what i did but
sometimes
sometimes like you want to get all them
boxes from amazon ian ordered like what
like 50 gallons of vinegar for some
reason
to go with the 50g and the lady and
the male ladies like pulls up with this
big old truck vinegar and she was like
why are these so heavy what are you
doing and i'm like i don't know one of
them was upside down and exploded
vinegar all over her truck yeah dude was
awful she's cool
[Laughter]
the mailman must be here every day for
like at least a half hour unloading
stuff
it's like 10 minutes dude i just get a
whim and i'll order one thing
that's another trip for the mail person
just like a bunch of vinegar and one of
them exploded in
her whole truck the whole time yeah
and then but we have to order things for
like for snacks for the gas to send like
batteries and stuff
so we you know we're running a business
so we do like a big order of batteries
and then this big heavy box they're like
what is this
we recently bought a whole bunch of
airsoft stuff this is a cool thing just
go in the backyard backyard
we got luke we went to the store and we
just basically bought a ton of airsoft
stuff
the lady was trying not to sell us the
stuff she didn't believe we were buying
all this stuff this is the craziest
thing
because i'm like okay we're gonna do uh
you know five rifles and five
airsoft you know handguns and then the
guy starts taking him down and luke's
like that we'll take that one and the
lady's like no no no no
what are you doing put him back put him
back it looks like we're buying it she
goes no you don't need this what are you
doing
and then finally it wasn't till i was
like i have a credit card
we are going to be buying this why well
luke's an instructor and luke is gonna
you know do basic trainings and like you
know
well if you do any firearms training
it's best to do it with airsoft first
especially with the type of caliber and
replica
possibilities that you have here because
you don't want to be using a railgun
when it comes to
practicing some real security somewhere
advanced stuff especially with people
who never held a gun in their hands so
you'd never want to do that so
airsoft is perfect it's fun it's fun and
we're we're working on the vlog and
we're getting ideas for it
and so we're thinking of putting up a
wall with like airsoft stuff we're gonna
have a lot of fun with it
but man she just didn't you know want to
let us buy this stuff
why was that i guess she just didn't
think she looked like riff-raff
yeah she looked like riff-raff she was
like you have a team and i was like no
we're just gonna you know horse around
you know but we have this big space to
do it so the next thing i think is what
we're gonna do with this with this uh uh
i'm hoping that we can get something big
enough
but actually really close so i can
actually build a house and live there
for the most part
but it might be difficult we'll see how
it plays out and then uh we might end up
just getting something really far away
that's just like
empty land and then we've got you know
rvs
and this is crazy this is interesting
dome housing is really easy to build
they're geodesic
yeah it's it's it's so it solves a lot
of simple problems for
you know burning man irl yeah i don't
want to send people
no burning man architect that can come
help us build those yeah it's like
you do like lattice lettuce aluminum
pipes or whatever and then they cover it
in plastic and then they insulate it
super cheap i've watched enough
homestead rescued and there we go
and you can build uh you can build dome
sphere you have to build spheres that
are
happening i literally lived in one in
new hampshire a couple weeks ago i had a
three-story one doubled one that was
connected and had everything running
through it
and it was just you can you can build
them modularly so like have dome here a
dome here in a dome here and then on top
you have like a dome here in a dome here
so you have
five domes and like a pyramidal for or
like it you can put them in
it's just really cheap it's like
substantially cheaper that's that's
really
really structurally sound like they can
handle do it let's go i'm ready handles
earthquakes and the rain and the snow
rolls right off
so it like makes a lot of sense so i'm
thinking like we want one big
super big dome concrete foundation
that's the challenge
that's expensive very expensive but if
you're wondering if we can use bitumen
instead
bitumen yeah it's like an advanced type
of plastic uh broken up that we should
be making roads out of but because of
plant
obsolescence they want to make it out of
what they use because it cracks every
year and they get to spend
i'll take whatever foundation we can get
maybe recycled plastics whatever
and then the idea is like you know just
to diy it man
to build the space and have a fun place
to hang out and also
you know a certain point working with
your hands having that farm
you ever you ever jack have you ever
grown food
isn't it amazing yes i have i in my one
of my last houses in dc i built an
elevated bed
farm in my backyard and i grew all kinds
of things and broccoli and eggplants and
tomatoes and peppers and all kinds of
we had eggplants that were like this big
i don't know what was going on
but like they grew this big it was
amazing and then we had a whole
field basically of broccoli and then i
came i came out the next day
man deer eating all right wow my herb
my urban deer so i love gardening i love
farming i've been reading a lot about
i can't wait to get back at it when i
lived in miami with this small farm and
we had chickens
and the first time the chickens laid
eggs i was like
can we just eat it like it was so i was
i've never done anything else before
and then like i just i was like yeah
city yeah city boy i
golden i'm like the chicken laid in
there can i eat it it's like enjoy
i i look i had never i had never uh had
a chicken before i
i didn't know the process by which they
you know eggs are ready to go and
now you just pick it up and then dude
every day more eggs more eggs piling up
like crazy we eat next like crazy
yeah man awesome let's get some eggs
gotta build a chicken dome
i wanna and you know what i do i'm gonna
3d print armor for the chickens
no joke so that way they don't peck each
other but also when like you know the
predators show up
the chickens when they do their natural
thing like defend themselves i'll make
it so that when they go like this spikes
go
there i was thinking if we built i saw
that on homestead rescue if you build a
big like house that's like a big giant
square but in the middle
is a giant open courtyard that we could
have a garden and all the chickens then
the wolves couldn't get in and no
i got you one better no no no you want
chickens in the middle of your house bro
what what no no it's not you're you
don't you know i'm sorry
i talk about her let him do it let him
do it
it's a great idea i have a better
solution
the three the 3d printed armor that
we'll have for the chickens
will have a thin mesh so that their
wingspan's expanded
and the chickens can actually fly oh man
that's the advanced technology
so suddenly the chicken starts flying
away
you know people don't realize this too
one thing is that the chickens can can
they they can jump like what 10 or 12
feet or something whoa yeah
because they can jump and fly but then
they like eventually come back down
so we had a rooster who kept jumping
into the other onto the other property
because he could hear all them sweet
sweet chickens
yeah and this rooster he was like i'm
gonna get me something then he jumped
over and all the roosters over there
were really big
and so they were like yo what are you
doing and started pecking him and then
he panicked and you couldn't get back
over because he was too dumb
it was a fight what kind of fight yeah
how about we go to super chat super chat
super chat
all right let's see by the way i'm jack
murphy you can follow me on jack murphy
live
on twitter and sub jack murphy live on
youtube please thank you very much
and and jack is here periodically
because not just every other wednesday
sometimes you'll pop in and you know
when the circumstances demand it yes
which is uh frequently no all right
let's go uh if you haven't already smash
the like button it's greatly appreciated
subscribe hit the notification bell
let's read some of these super chats
ground floor guthrie says for luke sent
you a message on parlor regarding
brushka brush calf survivalist classes
here in the east
check out dave canterbury and
self-reliance outfitters in ohio
and cole cracker in i believe western pa
cool yeah i'll check my pawler
parlor right now parlor or luke we are
changing
this is interesting uh jonathan
galterini says department of national
intelligence
blocked trump from exercising his
election integrity executive order from
2018
by missing the required deadline per the
dni official twitter account
i thought the deadline was uh like
tomorrow
no later than 45 days
no that was that was it was that the
18th yeah they moved it to the 18th
remember
catherine herridge was talking about it
they moved the report right so it's past
the deadline right yeah
it's over trump's you know everyone
thought trump was going to paul this
last ditch executive order of some sort
he got jammed up by the way when we
build the chicken house it's gonna be
huge
so the chickens will have like a lot of
space in the middle but it's gonna be
like shipping containers
all in a big rectangle and you living in
the middle of it
with the chicken with the chicken i'll
have like a room in one of the shipping
containers
that'll be great
mr sly mr sly trip says would you be
willing to invite david pakman on irl
absolutely yes i've known david for a
really long time i'd love to have him on
the show
but uh i think and i don't mean this
directed uh
directly at david but we've we've had a
lot of high-profile leftists some of the
biggest
be like i totally want to come on the
show and then later go butt covet
doesn't seem to stop any moderate
conservatives and there are even some
we've had
a handful of you know center-left
liberal uh or leftist types
we had jen pelman she was great vosh
came down he didn't seem to take issue
with it for the most part i invited vosh
to be here with alex jones and he said
he would want to do it because he was
worried about coving
and that was unfortunate because that
would have been that would have been
great he said give him like six
months he's like i'll be back give me
like six months i i want to you know
luke had this idea for the royal rumble
to get like do it big you know prominent
lefting personalities and writing
personalities
and then have like uh conversation slash
debate discussion
bloodsport yes kind of i think when
you're in person though it changes
everything
you know when people are on skype
they're like they're all screaming and
yelling
but when you get someone in it it
controls things a bit because people
they act like people around people it's
the great thing about
youtube collaborations in general when
you see like all your favorite youtube
stars in the same room and yeah
a lot of people talk like they've never
been punched in the face for saying
something rude online
when you see someone face to face
there's a big difference in how you act
indeed i like to just sit there and just
expand my presence
it works you're big man all right very
muscular thank you
oh my pleasure petty says the other day
ian mentioned revolution against taxes
rather than secession
that's at least half the reason the
civil war happened yeah it wasn't jack
you brought up federal income tax which
basically didn't get started until 1913
right and that's right around the
federal reserve got started
what a shock so they're extorting us i'm
down with getting rid of federal income
tax it's ridiculous
it's it's just like 100 years old you
know everybody would vote yes for that
right
i think we should get pretty much
everybody pretty sure you get like 90 of
america if like if there's a referendum
nationwide should we get rid of federal
income tax they'd be like yes
just yes let's do it yeah the commander
says tim talks about trump forming a new
party but he used to be part of the new
york independent party
they joined up with reform natural law
and a few other parties to form the
alliance party
which is populist center he should take
over alliance
yes and then all the trump supporters
should say
goodbye gop look the way i see it is
if you've got the political willpower
and the momentum the republicans aren't
doing anything for you
i guess the idea is with trump you know
in charge it forced the republicans
behind the trump supporters
to give them that you know that wind but
if the republicans now are like taking
the opportunity to throw the
trump support under the bus trump
supporters should be like without us
you're done
really well would never have won in 2016
with a third party
candidacy of course never of course and
so there is that that
red always red r voter that you need
i don't think i think if the republicans
right now formed another party
then uh if the trump supporters from the
new party they'd still lose
i but i think they would lose you mean
for 2024
i think they would start winning local
races immediately
i think they would start eventually
winning house seats faster and
and then we could see any other third
party the a trump supporter party
coming out against republicans would win
some house seats very quickly
not a whole lot maybe but in key areas
definitely like we've seen some weird
things happen but this is the
opportunity
to get an actual third party to break
through and tell the gop goodbye
and then things will start to change
because the republicans are plastic
i just don't want some cult worship like
it's about trump so it's about getting
trump into office
i don't you don't really need a party
around that of other people that are
like
trump no it's about it's about
constitutionalism look here's the thing
trump had an opportunity to build
institutions to build a network to build
think tanks to build a whole community
a whole ecosystem supporting maga
america first
all that and guess what the number one
thing that he failed at
as president building an ecosystem
building a party building a network
building an institution
this idea that he's going to just start
a third party
and build out an institution capable of
governing the country
is just ludicrous no it's just ludicrous
trump's not going to do it
trump supporters will eventually start
rallying around other people if you
don't have the leadership
then nothing and that's the advantage
right now you can't rely on trump to
just do it but you do have trump and
people believe in him
and the republicans have shown they're
absolutely ready
willing and waiting to knife him
figuratively in the back
if you're going to keep voting for
republicans and democrats then i'm going
to keep moving further away and saying
y'all are on your own man yeah that's
how i'm feeling yeah because they're
exactly so what's that what's the choice
stand up right now while you have the
wind at your back
and no look i think the democrats are
going to win in georgia
trump's not on the ticket the
republicans did well in 2016. you know
why
trump was on the ticket he inspired new
people to come on board nine million
people you pointed it out
2018 gone you know why trump wasn't on
the ticket that's right the new york
times said a large portion of trump's
new voter base
did not turn out because he wasn't on
the ticket so the
republicans lost the house in 2020
the republicans did really well regained
a bunch of seats took many house
house state level uh seats
and maintained control so far of the
senate
and their teetering trump lost
we'll see how things play i guess on
january 6th but
with no trump on the ticket and mitch
mcconnell i'll tell you this
everything aside mitch mcconnell coming
out the other day and saying please
don't support trump on january 6.
how many trump supporters are going to
be like okay mitch and i won't support
you on the fifth how about that
yeah do you think that they're um i'm
i'm
i'm sleeping on the senator's name from
west virginia
is there another yeah is there another
one like him
whose number who's number 49 out of all
those guys who
like closer to to moderate like for
example if the democrats in the senate
want to be like
a thousand supreme court justices and
then the filibuster
i mean are there not one or two yeah
mansion would be like
but is there one more is there one more
one more
democrat yeah who would be like i think
it's probably a bad idea to put a
thousand
supreme court i don't even i don't even
know if manchin would really stand up to
the party
like it's it's it's the political
establishment machine
you know all these these democrats who
won in 2018
promised moderate policy and kitchen
table issues and then the moment they
get
they got in pelosi went up to him and
started screaming good morning sunday
morning and they all said whatever you
say ma'am and voted for impeachment yeah
i say that to betsy every sunday right
good morning sunday morning yeah i love
it not intentionally it just comes out
by the way toxoplasmosis that's all i
have to say all right luke
all right let's do another one balion
says yeah man i'm an electrician of 15
years and i was cringing the other day
when you kept resetting the breaker like
uh we're going to hear that pool's
compound burnt down due to power
overloads
hopefully you've got an electrician up
there to help you out so here's the
issue with you
why did the breaker flip oh it doesn't
matter let's just throw it over again
well there's a real question because we
changed nothing and then we unplugged
half of the things in here
and the breakers still flipped so i was
like wow we got a problem yeah so the
electric
the electrician came in and said i don't
see a problem i can't tell you what's
going on
so we just ran a line to a different
circuit to split the load as much as we
can
but something happened that's bad and
the electrician couldn't see anything
wrong with it
we had two people look at it actually
one guy was just like it looks fine i
just don't understand
we didn't add anything up here we
actually took the playstation out
we reduced the load that we had in the
first place but for some reason
it was a windy day no post podcast
spelunky
no it's kind of good i got a ps5 now i'm
playing
i tried playing cyberpunk man it was
awful yeah cyberpunk was so bad have you
guys have you played it have you guys
played i have not i haven't gotten a
piece have you have you heard about
cyberpunk though i haven't supposed to
be like the biggest game and it is just
been in development for seven years and
the voice
is in it oh so it's behind the times
then it is the voice acting is like some
of the worst
i was impressed how bad it was the guy
being like
it's clear that the guy who read the
lines for the main character like had a
stack of script lines
and just read them one at a time very
quickly and went through them maybe they
were rushed i don't know
but it's like is this the job you mean
i have to do what i'll do it and i'm
like what is this like who's he talking
you're like
they need to have the voice actors like
working with each other and i was like
wow yeah big budget games have to treat
them like big budget movies if you're
gonna have voice acting it's
the world has reached that a threshold
where
movies and video games but they should
have known that i'll tell you that no
i'm playing i'm playing phoenix rising
that game's awesome
that game is real fun it's good would
you guys be interested in
running for president 2024
negative no would you be
president of a club that plays video
games and meets on sunday nights
d or something if we could do a
political
movement or party and we could maybe we
could push a candidate
like kanye someone that wants to be
president and get all our friends
involved like
joe rogan and alex jones and brett
weinstein kind of tried that with the
unity party and keep picking up the pace
with brett
but i think the problem was did he pick
dan crenshaw i'd be like i'd like to get
involved
yeah wasn't it wasn't it tulsi and
crenshaw or something we should get no
crunch on the show someday i like that
guy let me uh let me let me search for
this
that would be an interesting person to
have on brett weinstein called me one
day and he said who
should we promote as the president for
our unity party
and my suggestion to him was this
gentleman named john rob john rob
is an amazing technologist futurist
military strategist
understands the world in a way that most
people don't but he's one of those guys
that would just rather be behind the
scenes
yep gabbard and crenshaw and the trump
supporters hate dan crenshaw yeah
so that was a really bad idea i think
dan's all right but he is kind of you
know
a little too pro worry for my taste
soldier yeah didn't he just release a
cringy video
was that oh yeah totally what's
happening in the video so
did you see this video that dan crenshaw
put out i didn't it's really really
funny and
i think it's meant to be over the top
cringe because if there's one thing
conservatives know they can pull
off it's intentional cringe i'm not
trying to be mean but
conservative content is like never
really good like they try and do movies
they don't have it
but what the one thing they can do is
just accept it
and then roll with it and it's funny so
it's basically like he said
he's giving a speech and then someone
comes up like we got a situation and
then he's walking he's taking off his
suit like what's the problem and they
said
you know we got two candidates in
georgia and antifa so then he like gets
in a plane and then he like you know
jumps out of the plane and he's going
down and they're like you're going to
need to
they're like dan you're going to need to
uh you know change locations aunties on
the ground he goes negative
i'm going to take him on or whatever and
then he like from the sky with a
parachute lands on the hood of antifa's
car
and then punches through the window and
goes lafleur and purdue
republicans and it's super cringe but
it's funny
it's funny i think as long as he's
self-aware then it's then
it works you know what i mean but if you
really thought that was going to be like
a really cool badass thing he was doing
like i don't i don't think that's the
case i think i think he gets it it's
like
over-the-top silliness but yeah kind of
funny uh anyway i digress
tulsi gabbard's awesome i love the left
hates her and dan crenshaw i think he's
you know he's okay he's pretty cool the
trump supporters hate him
so like you know with all due respect
because brett's really really great dude
i like tulsi gabbard but you know the
left really doesn't like me
and they don't like elsie at all so i
don't know who this guy is enough people
involved that it
touches to you know enough of the
consciousness that people will support
just something new that where people
really believe in it and
doing the right thing you know upholding
the constitution they said jocko willink
as well
i think actually he would get a ton of
unity secretary of defense
yeah yes yeah ranked choice primary to
figure out who the candidates would
actually be you know the problem is the
best people to be
put in positions of power are the ones
that don't want it of course
the problem is the people who want it
the most and are egomaniacs psychopaths
are the ones
who usually get the position and those
are the positions that are usually drawn
to them
yeah i mean george washington didn't
want it
uh us grant didn't want it also
besides the story jefferson davis didn't
want to be the president of the
confederacy even they just named him and
he's like oh crap
all right daniel maxwell says off topic
but what do you guys think about
restricting all elected officials
state and federal to 12 years max of
being
of being in elected office i just said
we need uh you know mandatory uh term
limits for everyone
not just the president the united states
it makes perfect sense
i love it it's a complicated job it's a
complex world there's a learning curve
i don't know do you want a bunch of
rookies doing it all the time yes
because they're going to be ineffective
and not know what they're doing
and they're not going to get a lot of
stuff done and that to me is the best
thing government could do is stand back
and not do anything
yeah or the ones that are ineffective
and they vote for more programs and then
they're just even more of a waste and
bigger disaster
this is interesting uh bailey ray says
tim the town i live in montgomery texas
has not shut businesses down
nor enforced a mask mandate he made a
public statement early on in the
pandemic
and i can send a link if you'd like
freedom yeah i was mentioning this too
earlier when i mentioned there's this
town mossy brook where the mayor was
like nah we're not shutting down
there's probably a bunch of places where
they're like nah
we just don't hear about it because the
news doesn't cover these smaller towns
well and there hasn't been an incident
there's no incident unless the state
unless the state governor like
goes in and compels them you know with
the state troopers or whatever to
enforce
there's no incident it's not a story
maddie says people keep saying red
states would be a third world country
isn't texas and oklahoma economy
together the seventh largest in the
world
also best was to undermine authority is
through laughter we beat the
establishment by making them a laughing
stock in fact isn't that one of the
rules for radicals
ridicule your ridicule their most their
most important position
number 11 i believe yeah ridicule it
because you can't argue against ridicule
i was listening to a hotep jesus clip
he's really smart
he was mentioning that he's like this is
what they do so they they try and mock
you by saying if you come out and say i
believe in
in some kind of like you know certain
system to benefit us they'll say that's
white supremacy or something
that way they're essentially triggering
their audience and giving you putting in
a position where you can't even argue
because it's nebulous it doesn't mean
anything
says tim the supreme court actually did
the right decision by not choosing that
case
because that case would create the
president for other states to sue
the precedent for other states to sue
each other and trust me we don't want
that
eg california suing texas on tax laws or
gun laws
perhaps but i don't necessarily think
that
like the the court feature in the future
could say no
just because precedent exists doesn't
mean the courts have to listen to that
president they can overturn precedent
president my understanding is that when
someone says like i cite this law
they're basically saying this is the
laws that was settled before so you
should probably agree to it
but the supreme court can overturn past
decisions and pass the precedent
whenever they want
if they so see it born mexican raised in
america says tim a bill will be
introduced into the texas congress for
texan to vote to leave the union
texan have always been have always seen
themselves separate from the u.s
scotus really pissed us off but has have
we heard things like this before from
texas too
you know texas was its own country i
also read that
that when they were being admitted they
were given the choice to be five
different states wow but they decided to
remain as one
and there was some special provision
granted to texas when they joined
because they were their own nation
different from many of the
other states which were territorial i
bet they wish they had 10 senators now
[Laughter]
did you guys see halsey gabbard proposed
uh a bill h.r 8970 to repeal the u.s
patriot act
yeah yeah yeah that was with uh that was
with what wasn't with one other guy
thomas massey i think yeah massey yeah
yeah see tulsi is great
i like that thomas massey i like him
yeah thomas massie's good dude another
homesteader we could probably
get him on the show yeah thomas mansion
yeah i'll hit him up
thomas is tim right now i've already
talked about massachusetts
luke what the heck why i want to have
also the the the peak prosperity guy on
i think he's awesome
peak prosperity chris martinson i think
he would be a great addition just to
have on and talk to him because i think
he's done a lot of great work that has
helped people
but that's my opinion i would like to
talk to thomas massey too yeah
i'm i came to him through homesteading
and then i realized he was a congressman
wow yeah cool yeah he's a solar house
all right
he's got a beautiful house that he built
himself by hand it's incredible oh
it's awesome heavy timber made out of
stone from the property it's gorgeous
all right hayden said i think in order
to vote you should have to pass a u.s
citizenship test as well as a basic
civics test
if you can't pass basic u.s knowledge
and a test on how the government works
you can't vote
the issue i see is who administers the
test and determines the answers
you know i don't completely agree but i
don't disagree either like
you get a license to drive a car well
voting is serious shouldn't you just go
to you know and when you're registering
to vote you get pass a test so you
understand
how the process works and why it works
the way it does
sounds like it's interesting if the test
was just about how the process worked
voting is a right it's not a license
issued by the state
yeah well gun ownership is a right and
in many places
you need a license issued by the state i
agree i'm not saying if it makes any
sense
yeah there's a consistency there for
sure yep i mean dude
skin in the game older i understand so
many of the earlier
voting restrictions that were in place
now as i get older with more to conserve
i was so crazy when i was young i wanted
to say that i was like wait is he going
to talk is he going to talk to me
just let that last comment fester it
sure did
just looking for some uh some good super
chats you know just taking it easy
got a lot of super chats
sean williams says prosecutors dropping
charges is them telling rioters their
lives are worthless
that their lives are worth less than the
cost of the ammo used to end it the day
is coming when the people will take the
law into hand
and that's what i'm worried about i'm
worried i'm worried about that and in a
couple different ways
like in v for vendetta when the guy's
telling the story about what's he's like
i can see everything happening
and then he said lawrence says
eventually someone will do something
stupid and the cop
kills a little girl and then the people
just come out and start beating the cop
to death
i don't i don't think we're anywhere
near that but we're at a point where
cops are arresting business owners
sooner or later someone's going to get
seriously hurt
so unl if this keeps going on how long
until
someone actually violently defends their
property and their business
and then the cop who shows up shoots the
guy
big difference between defending your
property from a looter
and defending your property from a law
enforcement officer
wow that's that's a big step to take so
imagine what we're seeing now right
we've got multiple videos of business
owners
yelling at the health inspector the
health officials citing them
screaming you can't do this to me it's
not a law you can't do this and getting
fairly aggressive at a certain point
i i worry that somebody is going to you
know be in their business
maybe worries not the right word but i
mean it's possible i think would happen
and they're going to be like my life has
been destroyed
i'm starving i have no money and this is
it for me
i have nothing left to lose and they
just punch somebody in the face who
comes in their business the cops show up
and they say
essentially suicide by cop like this is
my last stand the movie falling then
what happens
then what yeah but then what happens
when there's a local business owner
imagine this possible scenario i don't
know how i don't think it's very likely
but just imagine
you've got a beloved restaurant the
neighbors always come down and they go
and they see you know you know
alan and he makes their sandwiches and
he serves them every day and he's loved
by the neighborhood
his life's been completely destroyed now
his he's ripped into a savings he's lost
his home
his business has been destroyed it's
been a year of lockdown they keep fining
him
and he says i have no choice either i do
this or i don't eat what
am i supposed to do it's like we saw in
in tunisia
the guy who sparked the arab spring the
government kept telling him you can't
sell your fruit anymore he had a fruit
cart
and they kept saying no so eventually he
went in front of one of the government
buildings and self-immolated
and then the entire north africa just
lit up
people snapped so imagine you have this
guy beloved member of the community
everybody knows him
he's a happy little old you know late
50s guy who's always the kid comes by
and he's like let me get you a sandwich
don't worry it's on it's on me and
everyone loves him
and then one day after finally being
beaten down he says enough
and then he tries shoving and fighting
and then the cops tase him
he goes down in a heart attack and then
the people who know and love him just
snap
and start beating the crap out of
everybody who was enforcing these laws
how long until people just break it
happened in tunisia
i think that there is a comparison to be
made here
uh with the perceptions in the
african-american community that the
police have already been doing this to
them
they've already been killing them
they've already been quote violating
black bodies in black space
and we've seen the reaction it's already
happening
what you're asking is is another
subgroup of americans
going to feel as though that the police
are their enemy and start
lashing back it's already happening in
america right now not not even like
and that big of a scale just like one
person so like i mentioned the
vendetta the little girl is running in
the street and the guy holds up the
badge and then shoots the girl and then
the people just come out and they don't
care anymore
so like what happens when i guess it's
not even about
the police in general they just don't
view him as a cop anymore they just view
him as a guy
who killed their friend and they just
don't care they got nothing left to lose
with too many people this business owner
and the people who live around them feel
like
every all is lost i'll tell you this
because i've now cited this like five
days in a row
it was a writing from ulysses s grant
who said anybody who feels that the
government is repressing them has
the natural right to revolution but just
know when you declare this
you are staking your your life your
property and your guarantees as a
citizen and should you lose you must
live under your conqueror
if they've already taken people's
property stripped them of their
guarantees as a citizen
and are now now putting their life in
jeopardy that's when you see arab spring
level snapback
i was just trying to explain this to my
daughter who's 15 years old just just
the other day in the car
and i got amped up and she's you know
she sees it
sort of my way but she's also in
montgomery county schools so she's
getting the leftist stuff
and i combat it all the time and i got
amped up man you're right you're
absolutely this this
we had revolution for less of an
infringement yeah seriously
we have had revolution for less of an
infringement than than what is happening
right now and what will be happening for
the foreseeable future
these are the conditions for revolution
it is in our history there is precedent
even other countries too i'm worried
it'll look more like syria though so
like i mentioned the arab spring the guy
in tunisia was trying to sell i think
was apples and fruit
and the government kept stopping and
stopping him and he couldn't survive
anymore
so he lit himself on fire everybody went
nuts
there was uh uh some some papers were
written about what caused the arab
spring
and one of the uh they said that there
were there's three components that
people need
and it's like food security and i think
maybe like water or something i don't
know shelter i think
shelter food insecurity like knowing
that you're going to be
safe otherwise you start getting anxious
when you have no security if you have no
shelter then
you have nothing to lose you have
nowhere to go and if you're starving
then you become absolutely desperate
and they're basically saying that the
price of food was rising so much
that people had become so desperate they
just snapped they were angry and fed up
and didn't care anymore
so i think the riots we saw earlier the
year were part of that
they redirected it into you know black
lives matter stuff
they controlled that flow of anger but
what happens when regular apolitical
people who just don't care and aren't
interested in politics are brought to
the brink and it's like it's like
they're being pushed every day
a few more feet to the edge of the cliff
eventually they're going to be looking
down going i can't go any further man
and they're gonna turn around and
they're gonna grab the stick and start
swinging with it what is so
weird i see happening is like these in
my town washington dc
so many restaurants have shut down so
many bars of clothes
for good permanent gone and yet
who do they blame they blame donald
trump
right so like where the anger goes is a
whole nother question there could be
that kind of anger
but where does it get directed when you
were describing that situation i was
literally thinking about
my family members and their stories
about the solidarity movement
where they fought back under communism
since again communism set up a martial
law
and it created a situation where people
weren't able to provide for themselves
weren't able to buy products weren't
able to survive
and then they revolted against the
communist uh
ussr state and fought back and
successfully were able to win
what was what did they do well well
there was a large
massive piece you know first it started
as a kind of very large peaceful
movement
it was a movement that solidified a lot
of the working unions a lot of the
working class as well as the church that
came together
and resisted and called for national
strikes that didn't cooperate with the
larger kind of system
that the ussr wanted the ussr literally
sent down
tanks and they were about to reinvade
poland
because of this mass movement that the
polish government tried to squash down
and try to destroy and we could talk
about this tomorrow because this
i have a lot of things to say especially
my uncle being sent
to jail and all these crazy personal
stories that i could share that
is is a huge testament to what i'm
seeing kind of
right now happening in the united states
that's a big red flag
and a big warning sign for me personally
and from where my family in poland came
from
yeah well so i was saying before us i'm
worried what we see what's happening
here might be
more akin to syria than it was like the
civil war revolution in that
you've got different factions that don't
agree with each other and so if we get
to the point where the pressure from
this lockdown
breaks people you'll have antiphon their
autonomous zones which we've been seeing
for some time
and they're armed militias they're
walking around with like you know ar-15s
and you know other
you know rifles and they're taking this
territory and saying it's theirs
well why would a conservative group
interfere they're not going to go to
portland they don't care about portland
they're going to have their autonomous
zone in their area eventually you're
going to have the joe biden
establishment apparatus
trying to quell different factions who
are pushing back and resisting
and then eventually you might see the
leftist group start to come together and
the right wing groups have to come
together
and then the left and the right groups
don't agree with each other but for the
time being the enemy of my
enemy is my friend yeah so what happens
after the establishment and this is
extreme hypothetical
what happens then if the establishment
you know government whatever just
crumbles and then you have the right
wing faction lefting faction
some kind of split all sorts of
cryptocurrencies will start popping
up i really don't think we shake the fed
federal
government they're trying to pass a new
law right now that will make
you having your own wallet your own
private keys illegal
the u.s tragedy department is trying to
thank you proposal right now exactly why
is trump doing something like this
that's absolutely ridiculous
no he doesn't know he doesn't know how
how many times can you keep saying that
until you really finally understand the
bigger kind of ramifications behind that
totally i mean dude i mean i've been i
supported him
and and and i support him 2016 2020
also openly critical the entire time and
this is one of the
key areas for sure tim on your last
point
funny to think who would be a great
unifying force
that would bring the far right and the
far left together
and you know who it is it's a kamala
harris presidency
yeah yes right that could be what makes
people on the far left the far right
actually see that they have a common
goal temporarily yes of course
temporarily
all alliances are temporary but then you
know
what might end up happening is one of
the you've got multiple
ideological factions with a singular
enemy and then once
you know they start winning or getting
ground they shove out one of the other
factions
of course i mean this is this is how it
works we'll win this fight and then
we'll deal with
our stuff later no but like even before
they've won once they start you know
realizing that
the establishment government is
weakening you get a mexican standoff
everyone's staring at each other and
it's like uh oh you know who's gonna
pull the trigger totally
yeah all right let's see nathan b says
the guy briefing crunch on the
commercial was marcus latrell the navy
seal they made a movie about
about him lone survivor also i'm a trump
supporter and i love dan maybe it's
because i'm a disabled vet
i don't think dan's as bad as everyone
says i think he's kind of a chill dude
and
he's someone you can talk to so he's
certainly you know but a lot of trump
supporters
really don't like him but the left
doesn't like tulsi and
and you know so i don't i don't see how
she's like i i like tulsa i think she's
great
but but i don't see uh
you know there's got i don't i don't
know who would be a better candidate
honestly i don't think there's a
unifying leftist candidate
unless it's an enemy like you said
kamala harris you know
someone someone said donald trump tulsi
gabbard 2024.
well mw says what the hell is up with e
n banks my god well i got
when i um you know i posted a thomas
jefferson quote on my twitter earlier
that's he thinks thought that standing
banks
are more dangerous or uh the banking
establishment more dangerous than
standing armies
and i once you see compound interest and
the way that they profit off of loans
um they used to call it usury which was
illegal but it was
by death they would kill people for for
requesting uh interest on laos
they don't do that anymore now they love
it yeah it's it shouldn't be a
for-profit
industry banking i don't think and and
the fact that they're
they're creating poverty and getting
rich off of it but
socialists up here yeah yep bro says
jack is wrong voting is not a right it's
a privilege granted that can be revoked
nowhere in the constitution does it say
that we have a right to vote
actually that's not true which which
isn't true
the uh that uh is wrong in the
constitution
amendment 17 it says senators will be
appointed by popular vote in each state
no actually i'm sorry i'm wrong uh that
doesn't necessarily still grant you the
right to vote as an individual it just
says senators will be chosen by a
popular vote
but then voting could be determined in
any which way it's not specified so i
was wrong on that actually bro bro i
believe is correct
yeah you got me all right let's see we
got here
nova zero says killdozer tim please buy
a bulldozer for your property
that is a folklore hero that embodies
the rage willing to cause damage but not
willing to take lives and unwilling to
be step stepped on by the government
his customer said nothing in uh said
nothing and tested a proof
you know the kill those are stories
you've told it to me sorry yeah that's
crazy you'll be closer i don't know
about all that but
a bulldozer that vibrated really fast so
it dug with its vibration so you could
cut through steel with it
are you super cool yeah
joshua insert says i believe the
disabled vets who are also trump
supporters have less issues with
crenshaw than you think
no you're probably right i'm not saying
every trump supporter doesn't like
crenshaw i just know that there's a lot
of them that that don't and i
i was joking earlier i actually have no
position i don't really know him
i think he's cool dude i think he's cool
dude um i think i disagree with him a
lot on a lot of issues but
you know the difference between him and
some of the like
older republicans is i don't i don't see
crenshaw as a crony corporatist
he's probably got policy positions i
don't like i know he's he's spoken in
favor of having a presence in the middle
east and stuff i completely disagree
far be it for me to tell him i mean he
was actually there and fought in the war
but then i see someone like tulsi you
know who's a major in the national guard
and maybe not the same experience as him
but you know i just don't like war
so but uh anyway jack uh thanks for
hanging out
hey thanks for having me tim thank you
very much lydia always so nice to see
you oh cool and apparently you have a
you have a website i believe and
i have a website i have a youtube jack
murphy live everywhere
youtube instagram facebook twitter also
especially got a book democrats are
deplorable is very good that's fantastic
people are saying people are
saying people are saying it's the best
great book the best people everybody
agrees
and if you're into things like personal
sovereignty masculinity and brotherhood
come down and check out our all men's
organization we have 400 guys across the
country
all focused on enhancing these elements
in our lives masculinity brotherhood
and sovereignty liminal hyphen order dot
com come down
join the list right on what's your
what's your twitter
twitter jack murphy live right on and
you can follow me on twitter instagram
parlor at tim cast check out my other
channels youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews check out this
podcast on itunes and spotify and all
other podcast platforms
leave us a good review if you're if
you're listening because it really does
help
the more we get subscribers followers
and reviews then they boost you in the
rankings and the more they do that the
more
other people see you and then watch so
it's the best way to help share and help
grow
the show otherwise just you know word of
mouth really helps if you like the show
please consider sharing it
we also got uh luke who's chillin yeah
thanks for joining us jack from the
north pole i know it's a very
busy time of year for you here you're
the one you're the one with the elf hat
on
i gotta point something out i gotta
point something out though someone made
a comment in the chat
saying that they don't trust men who dye
their beards yeah well that's not
i'm not your guy or beer fake news
that's why i brought it up so you can
correct the record the beard is
perfectly natural
my loving girlfriend who's a hair
stylist gave me a trim right
it looks extra good too but the color
just is how it the color is totally
natural and i'm testing out a beard
product
mad viking beard products testing it out
today we'll see how it goes
right on luke do you have so yes if you
would like to find more stuff for me
check out my youtube channel
we are change and and wow coincidentally
i'm also wearing uh one of the t-shirts
where you which you could get bill gates
is not a matter of fact
which states which states a fact which
you can also purchase on teesprings.com
we are chained up stores we are
teesprings.com we are changed just look
it up you'll be able to find it and that
supports my work and thanks for
allowing me to push that yeah right on
we also got this weird dude with
christmas
gorilla live strong
the opposite that's me auntie joe thank
you guys everybody so much and shout out
to you guys in the chat
that have been watching and supporting
us for so long and and
smash that like button yes like it and
share with your friends if you like it
as much as i do
i'm ian crossland you can follow me
online at ian crossland do you have
merchandise jack because i want to get a
jack murphy hat
i have some merchandise check it out
jackmarphylive.com
follow me on twitter i'll pimp it there
hard don't you worry about it
and don't forget to follow sour patch
lids who's pushing all the buttons i'm
pushing all the buttons in the corner
you can follow me on twitter sour patch
lids l-y-d-s
we will be back tomorrow 8 p.m live so
leave us those good reviews smash that
like button subscribe hit the
notification bell and thank you all so
much for hanging out and we will see you
all next time bye guys
you